hey guys
welcome to this full course on rpa
uipath
this full course video will cover the
core topics of rpa ui path
rpa is in demand and highly growing
field
uipath is the leading robotic process
automation tool
for large-scale end-to-end automation
for an accelerated business change
it provides solution for business to
automate routine office activities
so if you are interested in rpa and
tools like uipath
then you're in the right place this
video
will help you understand the concepts of
rpa ui path
so here is the list of topics covered
we'll first understand what is rpa
then look at the top 10 reasons to learn
robotic process automation
we will see some of the real time rpa
examples
followed by which we will look at the
comparison between
rpa tools like ui path automation
anywhere
and blue prism proceeding further we
will understand
what is ui path and then learn how
uipath is installed in the device
then we will see the uipath tutorial for
bigness
followed by which we will go through
uipath orchestrator
uipath robotic enterprise framework
uipathweb automation
and then we will see excel automation in
uipath
as to how excel is used in ui path
lastly we will see rpa developer
salaries skills resume roles and
responsibilities
and finally uipath interview questions
that will help you crack the interview
with ease
i am sure you are excited to begin with
full course
but before we begin make sure you have
subscribed to our youtube channel
and clicked on the bell icon so you
never miss an update from simply learn
so without wasting any further time
let's get started
this is jim he is an accountant in a
multinational company
he handles several invoices and other
financial records like monetary
transactions
liabilities checks and ledgers on a
daily basis
one of his tasks is to copy all the
relevant information from these invoices
such as the name of the company invoice
id and data processing into a
spreadsheet
and mail the sheet along with other
financial reports to his superiors by
the end of the day
as any prompt employee he transfers all
the information to the sheet
attaches the reports and sends them over
to his boss
via email every day but over a period
he starts finding this task to be time
consuming and repetitive
frustrated jim looks for a way to reduce
the time and effort it takes to complete
the task
and voila he stumbles across robotic
process
automation aka rpa using robotic process
automation
he builds a simple bot that extracts
information from several invoices into
an excel sheet
attaches all the necessary financial
reports and sends them over to his
superiors via
email at a specific time every day
so what exactly is robotic process
automation
robotic process automation rpa is the
use of software with artificial
intelligence and machine learning
capabilities to handle high volume
repetitive tasks
that previously required humans to
perform some of these tasks include
addressing queries making calculations
maintenance of records
and performing transactions there are
several misconceptions
about rpa rpa is not a humanoid robot
it does not have a physical form and no
resemblance to humans
rpa cannot replace humans or replicate
human cognitive functions
it does not have a brain of its own and
cannot perform
logical or critical thinking as humans
do
the working of rpa includes four crucial
phases
one the planning phase typically
involves gathering the processes to be
automated
identifying the test objects and
finalizing the implementation approach
two the development phase includes the
creation of automation workflows as per
the agreed plan
three deployment and testing is a vital
phase
since it uncovers any unexpected outages
and ensures a bug-free product
four lastly there's the support and
maintenance phase
which ensures that the product is
continuously updated
with smooth deployment across the user
base to meet the objectives of rpa
tools are used these rpa tools are
software applications that can configure
tasks
and automate them some of the popular
rpa tools in the market
are uipath automation anywhere blue
prism
work fusion pega and redwood among
others
when it comes to quality rpa ensures
consistent error-free output
leading to reduced operational risks
this in turn
improves customer satisfaction in the
area of delivery
rpa can help decrease the average
handling time and this enhances the
customer experience
and ensures 24 7 business continuity
with respect to cost according to nascom
domestic businesses can reduce the cost
by
up to 65 percent through rpa it offers a
higher roi by driving positive returns
within quarters
as opposed to years other advantages of
rpa
include reduced training costs minimal
utilization of i.t resources
and easier software migration today
many domains and industries like banking
and finance i.t
integration processes human resources
insurance agencies
marketing and sales and customer
relationship management
readily deploy rpa rpa service adoption
has been showing tremendous growth since
2016
and will continue to increase beyond
2020
according to mckenzie's research
knowledge and work automation
could have an economic impact of five to
seven trillion dollars by the year
twenty twenty five
it will impact more than two hundred and
thirty million knowledge workers
which constitute nine percent of the
global workforce
any company which is labor intensive
where people are performing high volume
high transaction functions stand to
benefit the most with rpa adoption
boosting their capabilities and saving
money and time
now that we've discussed what rpa is and
isn't
here's a question for you which of the
following is not
an rpa use case one email query
processing
two data extraction three
image recognition 4. payroll processing
give it a thought and leave your answers
in the comments section below
rpa offers the ability to automate
business processes
quickly and easily it pays the way for
digital transformation
by placing automation tools at the
user's disposal
so what are you waiting for get
certified
and become an rpa developer to build a
bright future in the field of automation
10 reasons why you should learn rpa
but before jumping into it let me give
you a brief insight into what
exactly rpa is now
do you remember the time you used the
digital calculator
in maybe your calculus class it made it
so much easier for you to arrive at an
answer
calculators undoubtedly helped you solve
complex mathematical problems
which previously required a lot of time
and of course doing manual calculations
have inherently
several errors but does calculation
account for automation well no
a conventional calculator requires
manual input
so this is partial automation automating
the usage of a calculator
that requires zero human intervention is
what rpa does
so what exactly is rpa
robotic process automation is the use of
software
with artificial intelligence and machine
learning capabilities
to handle high volume repeated tasks
that previously required humans
now some of these tasks include
addressing queries
making calculations maintaining records
or even making transactions
so why is rpa gaining popularity so
rapidly
and why do companies and techies have
rpa perspectives
so here are the 10 reasons why one
should learn rpa
so number 10 fast implementation
now getting data entry bots up and
running
goes quickly implementing a new rpa
software system certainly happens
much faster than training a new person
you can have these data entry bots up
and running in just
days in contrast if you wanted to hire a
new human employee
you'd be taking a lot of time in sorting
out resumes conducting interviews
going through the entire boring hiring
process and then finally when you find
the right person
you'd have to spend time and energy on
training them
however in case of rpa all of this is
countered
number nine we have no training time so
now this
is an important one if your process
changes
and the bots need to learn something new
you can either replace them
with new bots or alter their programming
now that again goes much faster than
training employees for new tasks
in terms of costs training an employee
for a new task will pan out
to be way more expensive and time
consuming
next up the bots will never quit now
with rpa
you don't have to worry about employees
quitting or dealing with the turnover
bots don't care how hard they're working
or how boring their job is or how
repeatedly they're doing the same tasks
again yes it would be ironic if the bots
got tired
software bots can work all the time 24
hours a day
every single day of the year at 100
capacity
now rpa doesn't take holidays it doesn't
have sick needs
and of course they do not have
unproductive days at all well isn't that
a treat to have someone who never
retires or decides it's time to move to
a different job
next up minimal i.t resources
maintaining software bots requires
minimal id resources
in some cases it doesn't id doesn't need
to get involved at all
your rpa systems will be managed by the
software provider
they're responsible for maintenance and
updates all of that
it completely takes the burden off it
and saves your company a whole lot of
money
roi is visible now every organization
wants to quantify their gains
many of these organizations do not know
how they should determine their roi
but when it comes to adopting robotic
process automation
roi is visible it defines a clearer path
to demonstrate its
returns
complex problems can be solved now as
our data
sources and analytical capabilities have
grown so has the time required to build
various reports
robotic process automation system is
ideal for solution
to solve these types of problems the
system stores the information and it can
also remember
and transform this information very
easily
that means this makes you auditable and
tax ready
software migration now it's a fact
that software migrations are time
consuming and costly
migrating to a new software could take
months and cost
could turn out to be tens or thousands
of millions of dollars
what's even more frustrating is that at
all times
certain features and functionalities
which may have functioned in a
particular way in a previous
version may not even be present in the
updated version
so rpa helps with data migration with
accuracy
speed and continuous updating of
software
rpa has a free tier many rpa vendors
offer
free tiers some of these vendors are
blue prism
automation anywhere ui path among others
these rpa software vendors are offering
high
rpa software notably ui path with their
community edition
and work fusion with their rpa express
this helps lower the total cost of
ownership
there's no rip and replays now rpa
doesn't jeopardize an employee's job
but helps with the growth of new jobs to
do your work
you need some additional software yes
and virtual machines to deploy
fully independent digital bots but you
may not
need to rip and replace your existing
infrastructures
also there's a common misconception that
rpa could steal our jobs
well that's not true monitoring and
controlling these bots are completely
the responsibilities of the developer
as a result rpa does not pull down your
existing systems
but it leverages them
lastly popularity and high salary
according to glassdoor the average
salary of an rpa developer in the us
is 77 000 us dollars and in india
the beginning salary for an rpa
developer is around 4.65 lakhs per annum
top tier companies like dell ibm
accenture capgemini cognizant among
others
are readily hiring rpa developers
now with that let's move on to the
growth projections of rpa
now looking at the graph here both rps
software
and services
increased by huge amounts during between
2016 and 2020.
according to mckenzie research knowledge
and work automation could have an
economic impact
of five to seven trillion dollars by the
year 2025.
it will touch more than 230 million
knowledge workers
which are which constitute about nine
percent of the global workforce
any company which is labor intensive
where people are performing
high volume high transaction functions
will boost their capabilities and save
money
and time with rpa
now this is all you need to know about
why one should learn rpa
but if you're looking to become a
developer let's look at some of the job
roles and responsibilities
rpa developers are responsible for the
creation
design development and implementation of
rpa systems
an rpa developer is expected to provide
guidance with process design
design develop test automation flip
workflows
deploy rpa components be it bots robots
or development tools
support the implementation of rpa
solutions
create process documentation and also
assure the quality of the automation
in this video we will be looking at the
robotic process automation example let
us consider a discussion between
john and jaime john is very curious and
wants to know
how and where rpa is used in different
fields
jaime being a developer helps john in
understanding the rpa examples
even if you are curious to know the
applications of rpa
then you are at the right place so let's
get started
the first example is customer service
let's look at the problem statement a
customer representative
must understand and solve the customer
queries carry out the necessary actions
by switching between the various
softwares and applications and inform
the customer
this must wait while the representative
is busy dealing with data
sometimes asking for information that
has already been requested
this tends to decrease customer
satisfaction and extends call duration
the solution requires identifying
frequently asked customer questions
assessing customer representative
actions in response to those questions
and developing rpa solutions to
facilitate those questions
when several sets of information need to
be coordinated across systems
the customer service representative can
launch a bot
the bot completes all actions in seconds
with the press of a button
for frequently asked questions a
dashboard can be created
a customer service representative will
fill out the necessary information
to receive the queries and bots will use
that data
in multiple systems to complete the
transaction
let's look at an example consider a
scenario
where a company was providing support to
the client and the company
was supposed to handle a large number of
calls
approximately 20 000 calls per month
which required a significant amount of
time spent in the support team
because of the system's complexity an
executive's average time was about 10
minutes
the system was inefficient and slow
resulting in a poor customer service
with the rpa solution the organization
gained a virtual team
that can complete the task in less than
a minute resulting in a drastic
reduction in an execution time
the rpa board performs the following
task loading a comprehensive customer
profile
obtaining a detailed billing information
user preferences and other user
information are being updated
resolving common but simple customer
issues
let's look at the second example
financial service
financial service involves compiling and
combining financial information from
various departments
and storing the records in a system data
is manually extracted
from a bank statements to reconcile
documents and link them to its forms
using detailed spreadsheets
to complete the reports business rely on
excel legacy software
and manual labor which is tedious and
time consuming
solution robots can generate invoices in
seconds
prompting clients to pay more quickly
rpa
in financial services tracks and
standardizes
and validates payments process orders
and avoids errors
and is always on top of things such a
disciplined assistant
makes the customers experience less
stressful adding value to the service
provider
rpa in finance eliminates the need for
endless email correspondence
and ensures a smooth payment approval
process matches invoices
to responsible parties and sets deadline
reminders
automated data entry speeds up the
process
and relieves human employees of huge
tasks this enables precise and
structured
invoice processing consider a financial
service company
that's having difficulty extracting data
from financial documents
efficiently and accurately in order to
generate ratings
using rpa company implemented an
application that recognized and
processed data
this enabled the client to quickly and
cost effectively automate
the tasks performed by rpa bots in
financial service are
investment management reconciliation of
bank statements
organizing the finances record of
accounts receivables and pay
the third example is hr service this
operation
includes numerous routine steps such as
interview scheduling
record keeping resume screening
candidate shortlisting
induction training and onboarding hiring
and firing place a significant burden
on hr and other support functions such
as i.t
security and facilities management
particularly for medium and large
businesses while it is expensive to
build a solution
that encompasses all of these functions
and completes the necessary tasks for
new or departing employees
some employees can be sloppy with
recording absences vacation or in
general
using the existing absence management
system
so the possible solution for this is rpa
can be used to collect and screen
resumes
and online application forms contact
through background checks
and compare the information to all the
relevant job requisitions
this allows the best candidates to be
shortlisted
rpa can be used quickly to create offer
letters for new employees
that are both personalized and accurate
and also validate records
by cross-checking data such as absentee
reports
against time logged in the corporate
network and alerting when information is
missing or inconsistent
talent acquisition team of a company
automated aspects of onboarding process
for new employees previously the
onboarding paperwork was completed
manually
by one person consuming a significant
amount of employees time
that could have been spent on more
valuable work
this type of work that no one wants to
do day after day
the company understands that an hr
department wants to provide a digital
and straightforward experience the task
required a lot of copy and paste
activities with the implementation of
rpa
the bot completed the onboarding
paperwork in less time
allowing hrs to spend more time on
corporate social responsibilities
hiring talent initiatives and improving
a company's reputation
the tasks performed by rpa bots in hr
service are
screening resumes onboarding of new
hires
attendance management induction and
training
employment management and survey report
the fourth example is telecom service
the telecommunications industry involves
high frequency of manual repetitive
rules-based processes all of which are
critical for providing appropriate
service delivery
thus the foundation of
telecommunications is made up of process
that are highly amenable to automation
for telecommunication companies
looking to improve their customer
service high reliability and accuracy
of process outcomes are required
solution the use of robotic process
automation in telecom
reduces error rates to close to zero
improves data quality
improves customer service and increases
operational efficiency
all while contributing significantly to
cost reduction
rpa technology can capture the business
process task performed by a telecom
company's employees
based on the employee section a
well-structured workflow can be
generated
which serves as the foundation for
automated process by mapping each
process step with its significant cost
for manual execution
it is simple to determine which action
should be automated to maximize return
on the investment
consider an example a telecommunications
and media company
decided to automate its order creation
and service removal process
to cut costs associated with the company
speed booster discount service
and deal with a massive amount of
transactional data
with the implementation of rpa it
becomes simple
to automate the order build process and
service removal activity
the tasks performed by rpa bots in
telecom service are
it checks on the credit and sim card
swapping the solution of customer
complaints
porting customer phone numbers
responding to questions
from partners
the fifth example is healthcare service
healthcare systems contain numerous
burdensome tasks that involve
significant resource allocation
such as claim management this results in
high operational cost
and slow process every industry has
inefficiencies
but few face the healthcare industry's
challenges
strict regulations regarding patient
data and lack of resources
to deal with such rules building takes
time after a healthcare service is
provided due to manual and repetitive
task in the management process
management process include document and
data input processing
and evaluation in addition to the
automating time consuming task
patients can schedule appointments
without the intervention of hospital
employees
credit to rpa technology along with
eliminating the need of resource
allocation for scheduling
by allowing patients to reschedule
appointments more quickly
this application can improve customer
relations rpa allows healthcare
providers to track and document each
process step
in structured log files to comply with
external audits
rpa improves data confidentiality
because boards handle this process
let's consider an example daily a
healthcare organization
deals with the process of patient
transaction data
customer detailed recording claims to
the process
and data reconciliation for healthcare
schemes are some of the manual process
they must streamline daily
the primary goal was to increase the
efficiency of existing approaches
to achieve greater accuracy with reduced
turnaround time
robotic process automation was
implemented and the most significant
possible impact was obtained
rpa platform handled claims processing
and health data reconciliation program
healthcare was able to reduce turnaround
time with this solution
the tasks performed by rpa boards in
healthcare service are
appointment scheduling regulatory
compliance
data entry and supporting analytics to
improve treatment
in this video we're going to compare the
most commonly used rpa tools
namely blue prism uipath and automation
anywhere
so what's in it for you first we learn
why exactly
rba came into picture and then what
exactly rp
is lastly we'll compare the tools based
on trial version
based technologies process designer
accessibility
macro recorders architecture learning
robots accuracy reusability pricing and
then certification
so without further ado let's begin and
understand
why was rpa introduced
consider the process of onboarding a
recruit to your organization the whole
process will involve
tasks like creating a new user account a
new email address
access rights documents retrieval and so
on so instead of doing all of this
manually
one can automate the process so with rpa
the user can automatically activate a
template for the onboarding workflow
rpa can help assess prepare and create
new join e data
initiate mailing of offer letters and
streamline the information across
different systems
so what is rpa robotic process
automation is the use of software with
artificial intelligence and machine
learning capabilities
to handle high volume repeated tasks
that previously required humans to
perform
now some of these tasks could include
addressing queries
making calculations maintaining records
or even making transactions
now rpe tools are the software through
which one can configure tasks
that are to be automated so some of the
widely used
tools are ui path studio automation
anywhere
blue prism work fusion among others
now assuming you have a basic
understanding of rpa
let's go on and compare the popularly
used tools
first up is trial version every tool
generally offers a trial version for its
users to get
acquainted with the tool this helps the
users
understand the tool better and decide if
they want to proceed with using the tool
blueprism offers a free trial version
it's available in two options
either on the cloud or on the local
computer
uipath also offers a free edition
both trial and license versions are
available
automation anywhere offers a free
community version
and both tried and licensed versions are
available
next up is base technologies based
technologies define the technology
with which the software was built blue
prism
is based on c sharp uipath is based on
microsoft vendors
like sharepoint kibana and elasticsearch
while automation anywhere is based on
modern java technologies
the third feature of comparison is
process designer
blueprism enables you to create design
edit as well as test
business processes from the visual
business object
now a vbo is like an adapter provided by
blue prism
for communicating with an application
each visual business object
implements a specific set of operations
on an application's user interface
so these are basically like objects that
encapsulate a particular functional
logic
uipath on the other hand acts as a
visual process designer
with developer friendly options now a
visual process designer is a dashboard
consisting of various tools
through which the developer can define
the automation tasks
automation anywhere is developer
friendly with a visual
interface built for business users along
with advanced features for developers
business users and developers can work
side by side to build bots
they can see the visual interface and
code in a single screen
the next feature of comparison is
accessibility
blue prism offers browser-based access
only
ui path and automation anywhere on the
contrary
offer both application based and
browser-based accessibility
in case of automation anywhere the
control room can be accessed
with a browser or a mobile application
this is the only platform
where users can create bots on any
device or any operating system
moving on to the next feature
learning now in case of blue prism
the user should have the necessary
knowledge of programming he should be
able to create business objects
and manage them in the control center ui
path enables you to design automation
processes visually through diagrams
the developer need not know a
programming language in particular
when it comes to automation anywhere it
is developer friendly
and offers both visual and programming
features
business users can build bots with the
help of drag and drop features
beginners benefit from the built-in
product walkthrough
next up is robots now before we jump in
let's discuss what the different types
of bots are
there are two types of quads we have the
front office bots
whose deployment is in the user's
control
we also have back office bots that can
run on locked machines from an
orchestrator
the user may not be actively involved in
its working
so moving on to the comparison blue
prism offers back office automation only
ui path and automation anywhere offer
both front and back office automation
in case of automation anywhere the hbc
or the human bot collaboration feature
enables humans
and bots to work together to complete a
task and also to manage exceptions and
escalations
moving on the next feature is macro
recorder
now the macro recorder allows you to
record keyboard activities
and mouse events to generate automation
scripts
these activities are arranged based on
the order
or sequence of actions being performed
on the screen
so moving on to the comparison blue
prism does not use a macro recorder
uipath makes use of a mac2 recorder to
enable fast process mapping
automation anywhere offers a universal
recorder so that the user need not
select
different recorders for different tasks
moving on to the next feature
architecture
an application that runs on the client
side and accesses the remote server for
information
uses a client server architecture
whereas an application that runs
entirely on a web browser uses the web
architecture
in case of a client server architecture
the user interaction with the server is
always through a user interface
or application on the client side on the
other hand
in a web application the user
interaction is thoroughly
through a web browser now blue prism and
uipath both
incorporate a client server architecture
automation anywhere incorporates a
cloud-native web-based microservices
architecture
it is the only platform that provides a
complete digital worker solution on the
web
users with any skill level can instantly
start building robots
on a browser without any heavy
installation
the next feature is accuracy blue prism
is accurate for desktop
web and citrix automation ui path
shines in citrix automation designed for
bpo automation
and automation anywhere shines in citrix
automation
with ai sense technology well
any automation solution built using a
virtual desktop or built to work in
virtual desktops
is called citrix automation
moving on to the next feature
reusability
blueprism consists of a library of
business objects
that can be reused across multiple
methods
it also offers high reliability
in the case of uipath the processes can
be used for various synthesis services
with several workflow modules as a
result
uipath offers a high degree of usability
and moderate reliability
in the case of automation anywhere apart
from the standard common library
users can develop custom actions upload
and manage packages in their enterprise
control room
every bot created in automation anywhere
is reusable
the bot store has hundreds of
pre-configured bots and digital workers
to kick start a user's rpa journey
next up is pricing blue prism has a high
cost of acquisition
it also offers restricted training
uipath offers effective pleasant
entry-level pricing
automation anywhere offers attractive
entry-level pricing
its users also experience the lowest
total cost of ownership
because of its native capabilities and
web-based architecture
moving on to the last feature
certifications
blue prism offers several certifications
like blue prism professional developer
blue prism rom architect among others
uipath provides free online training
and certification programs like rpa
developer advanced certification
automation anywhere university offers
free online training
and certification programs for both
students and advanced practitioners
professionals can also avail job role
specific certifications
there are several rpa tools in the
market today however
blue prism automation anywhere and
uipath are leading the market
let's get started with what is ui path
uipath is a robotic process automation
tool for large-scale end-to-end
automation
for an accelerated business change it
provides solution for business to
automate routine office activities
it uses a variety of methods to
transform tedious tasks into automated
process
daniel dines and marius tirka romanian
entrepreneurs
founded uipath in bucharest in 2005.
the first uipath desktop automation
product line was launched in 2013
giving business rpa tools to automate
manual and repetitive back-office tasks
let's look at the features of uipath
drag and drop workflow the user of
uipath will develop visual process steps
by dragging and dropping related tasks
onto the graphical workspace
then with the user interface properties
they can transform those process steps
into a visual workflow
users may also use the recorder wizard
in the uipath tool to build web based or
application workflows
the next feature is record and playback
the user can use this function to record
actions
and transform them into automated
process series
ui path has the following types of
recording options
basic recording it focuses on automating
single task and is commonly used to
develop each activity's complete
selector
desktop recording it can be used for a
variety of actions
as well as actions development web
recording
it is a common tool for viewing and
recording web page activities
citrix recording it is very widely used
for recording stuff like pictures and
virtualized environment automation
next we have inbuilt activities in
uipath uipath comes with over 300
built-in activities covering a wide
range of process automation and
application integration design tasks
these activities are found in activities
pane which covers most design
tasks such as data extraction data entry
and automation
next we have advanced scraping options
scraping data from web pages and
applications
is easier with ui path screen scraping
furthermore the data screen scraping
wizard helps in scraping of data with a
repetitive structure
scraping solution works flawlessly with
any program
including.net java flash pdf legacy and
sap
next we have high security and
robustness we can create super smart
durable robots with uipath
with a simple visual canvas everyone in
the company can use
bots ui path offers high security auto
login functionality
to run the bots and operates with a
locked screen allowing automated process
to run in complete privacy
let's look at the components of uipath
the first component we have ui path
studio
uipath robot and ui path orchestrator
let's look at them one by one this is
how a ui path studio looks like
ui patch studio is a user friendly
interface
inside the tool that allows user to
visually plan and design various
automation process
through diagrams using drag and drop
functionality these diagrams are merely
a structural reflection of specific
tasks
that must be completed this is the
activity
pane in the ui part it consists of
project
activities and snippets
this is the ribbon tab it consists of
saving options opening new files
debugging files recording screen
scraping data scraping and many more
we will explore this in the demo section
next we have output pane where output is
being displayed
and we have the properties pane where
the properties of each activity is shown
here
the next component is uipath robot after
you have built your process
the next move is to put into action in
the ui path studio
uipath robots are used to translate the
process into tasks
which are then executed these robots are
used to assign various tasks and carry
them out in the same manner as humans
but
without human interference when given
operation occurs on the computer
ui path robots are programmed to begin
executing tasks automatically
next we have uipath orchestrator the
orchestrator
is a web-based application in uipath it
has features like
deploying monitoring scheduling and
controlling automated bots and process
it's a centralized forum for managing
and controlling all software bots
let's look at the architecture of uipath
it consists of two sections
the client side and the server side and
the three layers
let us look at them one by one we will
first look at decline side and the
server side
client-side ui path components are those
that the user or developer can
communicate with directly
uipath studio uipath robot browser and
uipath
agent are usually included ui paths back
and operation are considered server side
the tasks and workflows that a user
produces are saved in the databases
uipath orchestrator chooses the
necessary function and the software
robots
to carry out the code's task the robot's
locks and statistics are stored in the
back end
locks are useful for analyzing robot
performance and detecting errors
in them the two elements comprise the
uipath robot
agent support for ui path and the
executor service for uipath
the agent support for uipath is a
service in ui path
that serves as the mediator between the
client side and the server side of
uipath
all of the information and data are
conveyed via the handler
messages are also logged into the
orchestrator before being moved to the
sql server
the service can be used to search all of
the currently available tasks in the
device tray
it also can change device settings and
start and stop the current task
execute a service for uipath in this the
software robots use this service to
carry out the tasks specified in the
windows session
now let us look at the three layers
first one is the presentation layer
this uipath components that are open to
the users
make up the client layer ui path studio
robots
browsers ui path agent and executors
for example a user or developer may use
these components
to design and create different tasks
that can be automated
computer robots are commonly used to
complete this task
the client layer is an another name for
the presentation layer
let us look at the service layer the
uipath's architecture's most
significant sheet the cloud layer shows
all server information
the ui path orchestrator is the most
significant part of the server layer
when the robots can perform the task the
entire project is periodically uploaded
to the server
within the aid of an orchestrator the
project is often carried out through
several structures
the orchestrator is in charge of the
whole band it keeps track of the project
development
scheduled software robots for execution
and produces summary reports based on
the filtered parameter
it assists in the synchronization of
software robots so that they can
continue to perform routine tasks
it helps our project meet project
requirements service levels and
deadlines
thanks to its web-based management
system
now let us look at the persistence layer
database servers
make up the bulk of this sheet during
this layer
all of the robot's configuration
information is saved
users insert data robots assigned tasks
logging information and assets among the
other items into the orchestrators
configuration details furthermore
persistency layer is in charge of
keeping the log information
updated by the ui path agent services
elastic search is used to store these
locks the locks are primarily useful for
locating and correcting errors
process level data is usually saved in
relational database management system
such as sql server
this makes processing logs from the vast
volume of data a lot simpler
hence the queues tasks are often taken
care by the persistency layer
let's look at some of the applications
of uipath
in sales in sales ui path is used to
generate invoice
this is an example of data replication
in action
both crm and accounting systems must
have the same sales details
bots can update accounting records
prepare and send invoices from the
appropriate email addresses instead of
manually replicating data
it is also used in keeping scorecards up
to date companies that do not have hr
and crm systems
integrated can use rpa boards to ensure
that crm adjustments are submitted to
scorecards in real time
allowing sales reps to track their
progress
it is used in crm updating a new class
of solution
is evolving to incorporate their email
call and other contact data into crm
a simple bot could be written to update
your crm records with customer contact
information
if you can't find a suitable solution
for using the crm
systems next it is used in banking
in banking it is used to check kyc
though dedicated kyc solutions are
evolving rpa bots can be used to
automate portions of the kyc process
if your organization does not want to
use one
a case may be referred to an employee in
the event of an edge case that requires
human
involvement it is used in sanction of
loans
like most document process activities
this method is
appropriate to rp automation because
complex business logic can be embedded
in bots
which can partially automate loan
decisions and the manual process that
follow
it is used in execution of trade rpa
bots may be useful in situations
where legacy systems are incapable of
storing complex limit orders
however this is more a band-aid solution
in the long run
switching to a sophisticated and
competent trading system
will certainly be a smart investment
considering how it could increase
trading and minimize trader workload
next it is used in healthcare in
healthcare it is
used for appointment scheduling the rpa
bot makes appointment for patient
based on their diagnosis doctor
availability location
and other factors such as financial
statement and insurance details
it is used in supporting analytics to
improve patient treatment
rpa bots may collect a variety of
medical information
rpa boards for example can use patient
data to a third party healthcare
analytics provider to provide more
reliable diagnosis
and better patient care without
violating any confidentiality
regulations
let's look at the benefits of ui path
increase productivity ui path automates
with quick speed and accessibility
consider an rpa board that allows a
worker to produce a monthly report
in 20 minutes instead of manually taking
4 hours
the company's productivity could
increase as a result of process
automation next we have high efficiency
rpa software does not need a break it
can operate
24 hours a day a single rpa robot may
replace two to
five full time workers if not more
robots can do the same amount of work in
less time or more work at the same time
than humans
customer experience in rpa adopted
business
routine and repetitive and boring tasks
are assigned to robots
allowing employees to focus more on
customer service
company may meet consumer needs with the
help of professional and knowledgeable
employees
highly secure there is no risk of
information leakage from one component
to another
because it performs single task as a
result data access is strictly monitored
and reported
cost effective ui path has minimal
operating cost
and more efficient use of it resources
let's look at the top companies hiring
ui part developers
infosys ibm deloitte
ey kpmg tata
tech mahindra and capgemini
let's look at the salary trends for ui
part developers
the average pay scale for a uipath
developer in india
is 5 lakh 45 000 rupees
ui part developer salary ranges from 362
000 rupees to 1 million
in usa the ui developer's salary ranges
from
58 000 to 107 000 dollars
and the average salary is 76 000
let's look at a demo consider a scenario
where you have multiple excel files you
want to combine the data in single file
in this demo we will merge two excel
files into a single excel file
and send it over an email let's create
automation to merge two excel files
using ui path
from here we can open a new project or
existing project stored locally or
on version control system with the click
we can open a new project or create a
new project from a template
uipath offers many templates depending
on what you are trying to do
for now let us start with a blank
project
so we'll open a blank project here so
we'll open our main workflow
we'll go to new and select a new
sequence
we can do it using a flowchart as well
but for now i'll show you
doing a sequence so we'll open the
sequence
and we'll name the sequence since we are
merging two files i'll name it as
merging files
and i'll create it
so we'll go to the activities pane
firstly we need to drag and drop a read
csv activity
so search for read csv
so drag and drop read csv activity
since we are using two excel files so we
need to read csv activities
and read from the file we need to select
the file location
so we'll select the file location
sample csv file one
and at the file too we will select
another file location
sample csv file
at the output side will create a
variable
and name it as sl underscore file y
similarly for another csv
we'll create a variable and name it as
sl underscore
file 2.
so this much is done now we need an
assign activity
so we'll search for assign activity
so we'll drag and drop
assign activity has two parameters two
and enter an expression
so in the two we'll create a variable
name name it as merged
a cell and
and in the expression write an
expression
say excel underscore
file 1 dot clone
why are we using a clone function the
clone function creates a new data table
with same structure but does not copy
the data
oops it's showing an error here so
what's the error
so we need to assign the variable
type to be
system.data.data table
here we go error has gone
so after using the assign activity we
need to merge the data table so
we need merge data table activity so
search for merge data table here we go
drag and drop it
we need to merge data table activities
so drag and drop
and specify the destination and source
here
the destination is the merged sl
and the source is the sl underscore file
one
for the first data merge table
similarly for second merge data table
destination remains same
source will change to sl underscore file
too
this is done so next we need to drag and
drop a write csv file
right csv file creates an output file in
which you want to merge the two files
so search for
write csv here we go
drag and drop it
so choose the path create the file so
you can see there is no output file here
so we'll create the output file now
which is an empty file
so output dot csv
so we have created an output file
so right from we'll write it as merged
excel
we need the data from merged excel
[Music]
so the output file is created so now we
need to send the file over and mail
so for that we need to drag and drop a
get password activity
so we'll search for get password
activity
here we go drag and drop it
and once you get this get password
activity enter the password here
enter your password email id password
so there is a prerequisite when you use
get password
to receive a mail go to your google
account
in google account go to your security
option and in security there is an
option called less secure app access
turn that on i'll repeat turn on the
less secure app access
okay once the get password is done
go to the results section in the results
section right click and create a
variable
name at something maybe sss
so i've created a variable there
so we need a last activity now that is
smt mail message smtp
mail message drag and drop it
so in the host port and enter this
server
so the server you have to enter it as
smtp
dot gmail all should be in the double
quotes
smtp.gmail.com
and enter the port number as 587
and enter your email id here which is
your own email id i'll enter my
once you enter the email id enter the
password
what we had created
so that's done so enter the email id
here
enter the subject whatever you want
so i'll enter it as merged data
most excel files
enter the body
so we'll attach the file
so what is the file which we are
attaching
so we are attaching the output file what
we have named it as
output dot csv file
so that's it we'll run the program we'll
run the code
sample execution has started
and within the 10 seconds sample
execution has ended
so we'll go and check if we have
received the mail
so this is my email id
here we go we have received the email
here let's open this
let's open the output file
here we go you can see the data has
being merged
and if you go to the file where the
documents were stored here you go these
were the two files
the sample file one and sample file two
and this is the most file which was
created
let me show you the sample file 1
and sample file 2.
so this is the sample file 1 with 10
rows
and this is sample file 2 which also has
10 rows
so this is file 2 with 10 rows and file
1 with 10 rows
and here we go this is the output file
which has both tent and rose merged here
here we go it is sent over and made
in this video we will be looking at the
installation of ui path
so let us see the requirements
we will first look at the hardware
requirements the cpu
should at least have a processor of 1.4
gigahertz
32-bit configuration or it's recommended
to have a 1.8 gigahertz
64-bit configuration the device
is recommended to have a ram of 8 gb
if not at least a minimum of 4 gb
let us look at the software requirements
if you are using a windows operating
system
then windows should be of version 8.1 or
8.1
n or 10 or 10 n and the windows server
should be of 2012 r2 2016
or 2019 versions another prerequisite
site is to have
dot net framework of minimum of 4.5.2
version installed
let us look at the additions the
different editions
that ui path offers uipath offers two
types of editions
community edition and enterprise edition
community edition
is for the developers and small teams
who are just starting on their
automation journey
the enterprise edition is further
classified into three types enterprise
studio edition
enterprise cloud edition and enterprise
server edition
so enterprise studio edition is for
individual enterprise developers
who want to experiment with ui path
studio price cloud
is a cloud-based deployment of entire
rpa enterprise platform for any size
business
enterprise server on premises deployment
for
entire enterprise automation platform
for large-scale business
let us look at the different profiles in
uipath ui patch studio x
ui path studio and ui patch studio pro
ui path studio ax is for business users
if you are not a developer but if you
want to automate a simple
task then it is easy to use a studio x
uipath studio it is for rpl developers
build complex automation that is run by
attended or unattended robots
ui uipath studio pro it is for
specialized developers
automate with the ai advanced rpa
features
testing tools and sophisticated coding
services
so we will look at the installation let
us install uipath
go to any one of the browser and search
for uipath.com
this will take you to the official ui
path website
here you can see try uipath for free
click here
since i have already registered before
it is showing as continue to existing
organization
if you are visiting this website for the
first time then
you might have to register or sign in
using an email account
after signing in and filling all the
details you can continue
here you can see download ui patch
studio
click on this and download the ui path
studio
here you go the ui path studio setup
file is getting downloaded
once the ui path file is downloaded run
the setup file
and here you can see the ui path is
getting installed after installation
it will ask for a license select
community license
which is free after selecting the
license you need to choose a profile
there are three profiles
ui patch studio pro which is the
advanced studio ide
it has features like testing tools
advanced rpa features and coding
services
another profile is ui path studio it is
for developers
who have prior programming experience
and the last profile is the ui path
studio x
it is for the people who don't have any
programming experience
so we will select uipath studio x for
now next ui path will ask you to update
the channel
you can either select the stable version
or preview version
we will select the stable version for
now after you select the versions you
need to select the source control
plugins
you can enable git version control
system or apache sub version
and azure develop server ui path
provides a short introduction video
tutorials to learn how to build
automations following step by step
instructions and an academy to take free
training on the uipath academy
so that's it you have successfully
installed uipath studio
from here you can open a new project new
template
and start building the first automation
in this video
we will learn about ui path studio in
depth and understand it's working with a
demo
so what is ui path now rpa
is a technology with which human tasks
can be automated
to facilitate this a tool is required
uipath is one such tool among others
that are used to create bots with the
help of visual processes and diagrams
it provides complete end-to-end
automation calling it hyper automation
ui path was founded by daniel dines and
mario sterka
in 2005. uipath is specially used for
windows process automation
it automates repetitive tasks and lastly
uipath offers drag and drop
functionalities to make it easy to use
now since there are so many other tools
like blue prism automation anywhere in
the market
what makes ui path stand out so let's
look at the advantages of uipath
first uipath has an activity library
this library has several built-in
activities and features like display
message
input box and so on this improves the
customer experience
we will deal with these activities in
the demo later
next up is security rpa deals with a
variety of information like credit card
numbers
financial information and passwords
uipath
offers extensive security since all the
information can be encrypted and stored
on a centralized
server up next we have recorders
so ui path uses a microrecorder to
record
the user actions such as mouse clicks
and keystrokes
once the actions are recorded they can
be emulated
using emulators for quick automation
third-party integration uipath can be
integrated with
third-party plugins like ibm watson and
google plugins
then we have powerful debugging ui path
studio
comes with a debug component that helps
find and locate problems easily in
complex workflows
this is useful for viewing the execution
of each activity to verify what data it
gets
and if there are errors in producing
outputs
now let's understand the various ui path
products
first up is uipath studio this is the
platform to create the bots
this product consists of all the
necessary drag and drop activities
and a robust ui to help develop bots of
your choice
now the uipath studio consists of the
gui dashboard
it offers a visual dashboard with
activities like send email
display message and so on then we have
types of recorders
uipath studio offers various types of
recorders to record actions
on multiple platforms then we have
logging
and exception handling it offers various
options for debugging and exception
handling such as debug
open logs slow step etc and finally
we have reusable components the user can
create reusable components to publish
them together as libraries
next we have the uipath robots all the
automation tasks that created
are run by uipath robots there are two
types of robots
attended robots and unattended robots
attended robots
work with you to speed up service desk
and help desk
it is used in activities where human
involvement is the key
unattended robots operate without human
touch maximizing cost and performance
benefits for any variety of back office
tasks
lastly we have the uipath orchestrator
the orchestrator is like a centralized
entity where you can deploy
secure manage all your automation tasks
here are the steps involved first
you create a bot now you create a
project and publish it as a process for
further use
once a process is created it is assigned
to a specific robot to execute
in an environment this collectively
constitutes a job
now let's move on to the architecture of
uipath so on the top
you have the client layer consisting of
uipath studio and the uipath robot
now the uipath robot has two parts
one is the uipath agent service which
displays all the available jobs
in the system tray and the other one is
the uipath executor service which is
used to run the jobs in one windows
session
the server layer receives the robot once
it is ready for execution
with the help of the orchestrator you
can run the project on different
pcs the orchestrator monitors the
deploys
configures queue management and logging
lastly we have the persistent layer
which consists of the databases
it takes care of the queues and holds
information about the robot
configuration and their assigned
processes
now that we know what ui path is let's
acquaint ourselves
with its user interface and understand
its components better
so this is what the typical interface
looks like
first we have the ribbon it consists of
three tabs
home design and debug home
is where you start a new project from
pre-defined templates or open a project
you recently worked on
by default the projects are created in
the location shown below
next is the design tab design tab
adds sequences flowcharts and state
machines to your project
it installs and manages activity
packages it builds interactions with ui
elements and then publishes your work to
orchestrator
finally is debug it debugs your workflow
by using debugging tools to set up
breakpoints monitor the execution of
activity step by step and adjust the
debugging speed
next on the screen is tools so the tools
tab can be used for installing
extensions from chrome
firefox edge java silverlight
citrix and windows remote desktop and is
also used for launching the ui explorer
and project dependencies mass update
tool
then we have settings the settings tab
has options for changing the interface
language
theme setting global preferences and
managing activity feeds
so you have general settings then there
is settings for design
locations managed resources and finally
license and profile up next
you have help the help tab directs you
to product documentation
release notes online resources the
community forum and the rpa academy
after that you have the recorder
the recorder component in uipath studio
allows the user to record ui mouse
movements
and keyboard activities to generate
automation scripts after that
you have scraping so uipath studio
supports two types of scraping one is
screen scraping and the next one is data
scraping
so screen scraping is programmatic
collection of visual data
and data scraping is the extraction of
structured data from an application
then you have user events user events
records events such as mouse clicks and
keystrokes
then you have variables so variables
hold different types of data
these variables can change over time
uipath makes an easy provision to create
and remove unused variables
on the bottom left you have project so
the project panel enables you to view
the components of the current project
add folders open the file location
manage dependencies
and adjust project settings beside it
you have activities panel so the
activities panel
shows available activities that can be
added to the current workflow
users can use the search box to find
activities navigate through them
using navigation keys and press you also
have the snippets panel which enables
you to easily reuse automation
it includes by default multiple samples
and snippets
to the bottom right you have the
properties panel which is contextual
and enables you to view and change the
properties of a selected activity
you also have the outline panel which
displays the project hierarchy
all available variables and nodes you
can highlight activities in this panel
by selecting them in the designer panel
the output panel enables you to display
the output of the log message or write
line activities
among other things exceptions for
packages are also displayed in this
panel
so now that you have understood the
interface of uipath let's look at the
companies using uipath
so you have accenture capgemini
cognizant
ethos and deloitte to name a few
now we'll do a demo to automate a task
using ui path studio
so here is what we are going to do in
the demo we will create an automated
process to fetch data from a website
wherein the bot would extract data like
the name of the person
the phone number and the email id this
data will store it in an excel sheet
and send it over an email now let's get
started
now to do this demo we'll be using the
fake name generator website to generate
random data of people and store this
data set in an excel sheet
now if i had to do this manually i would
first create an excel sheet
so let me open an excel workbook
i'll create a blank workbook
so this is where i'll put my data if i
had to do it manually
so now let me take you to the fake name
generator website
so i'll search for fakenamegenerator.com
so this is the website where you can
generate
fake names now
if i had to store this data in excel
i would manually copy paste each and
every detail
and paste it onto the excel sheet so for
that
first i had to create columns like name
then phone number
this in an email
after that i had to come back
to this and
copy each of these fields
it's the name
if i had to take the phone number
so i would copy this
and similarly for the email address as
well
for one record it is fine what if you
are asked to fetch 100 records or say
200 records
then this method is not at all feasible
it is time consuming and inefficient
you need to find a way where you can
automate this task
of fetching records uipath
is a solution for this so let's see how
we can automate this task
using the uipath studio so i'll click on
open
main workflow first
we need to direct ui path to go to the
fake name generator website
for that we need the sequence activity
so let me search for sequence here so
under activities
i'll search for sequence
and i'll drag it
here
after that i need to open the website in
a web browser
so for that let me search for another
activity called open browser
so under activity i look for
open browser
so i'll drag it on the sequence itself
now it is asking you to insert the url
of the website
and it must be within double quotes
so i'll go to my website
copy paste the url
i have to give this url within double
quotes then i'll paste it
now we need to select the name of the
browser where you want to open this
website
so under input and browser type
i'll choose chrome
now let me go ahead and run this file
so under debug
i have run file i'll click on it
so as you can see the website is
automatically opened in a new window on
chrome
i'll close this
the next step in the process is to tell
the program how many records we want to
fetch from the website
for this we will create an input dialog
box
so under activities
i'll search for input
so here you get the input dialog box
i'll drag and drop it on the top
now it is asking us to give the details
so i'll put it within double quotes say
enter the details of customers
or say people
and then here i'll give
enter the number of
records you want to fetch
now now i have to store this information
in a variable
so under variables
i'll create a variable and name it as
total
is the total number of records i want to
fetch
similarly under output result i'll give
the same variable
name as total
now we need to fetch the details a
number of times repeatedly
say for 10 times or 20 times or 50 times
to do this operation i'll be using a do
while loop
so to use a do while loop
i'll first search for do while
and i'll drop it to the do section of
the sequence
as you can see do while has two
components
one is the body and the other one is
condition
the body has the things that you want
the program to do
the condition is where you evaluate
certain conditions every time when the
program has to do a task
so for every step or iteration it will
check if the condition is true
or not and go inside the body of the
loop
now for doing this we need to assign a
variable
so let's name the variable
as val
and i'll change the variable type to
integer
and i'll make the scope to sequence
i'll also assign a default value of 0.
now we'll compare this val to the
variable total
so the condition i will give is check if
val is less than total
so under condition i'll give
val less than total
so every time the value of val is less
than the total
it will keep fetching the records from
the website
you can see it has thrown some error
now this is because our total variable
is of type string
while the val variable is of type
integer
so you can't compare an integer
with a string variable so that would be
absurd
we need to convert the total variable to
an integer using the same function
so here itself i'll write c int
which is convert this total variable to
integer
you can see the error is gone the next
thing i want to do is if the value of
the valve variable is less than total
i'll increment the value of val to 1.
so to do that i'll use an activity
called assign
so i'll check for assign
and i'll drag it onto the body
so here i'll give val
equals to val plus one
this will make sure the value of val
increases by one
every time there is a new record
inserted it will continue until the
value of val
no longer matches the total
so the next job is to extract
information from the website
to do this we will use the get full text
activity
so i'll search for get full text here
and i'll drag it right below the assign
activity
now you need to select the information
which you want
so first i want to get the name i'll
click on the indicate element inside
browser
and then select the name of the person
so i'll click on this
and i click on the name
there you go now we need to store this
name in a variable
so i'll create a variable
so under variable i'll create
a variable called name
and in the output also
i'll give the same variable name
next i want to fetch the phone number of
the person
so i'll again select get full text
and i'll drag it
here
i'll click on indicate element inside
browser
so i'll scroll down and i'll select the
phone number of the person
so we have selected the phone number
similarly i'll store this phone number
in a variable
so i'll create a variable called
phone underscore number
and the output text box also will
give the same variable as
phone underscore number
after that i want to get the email
address of the person
so i'll continue with the same drill
i'll select the activity once again
which is get full text
and i'll drag it right here i'll click
on indicate element inside browser
and now
we'll select the email address which is
this one
similarly i'll store the email address
in a variable called email underscore id
and in the output also we'll give the
same variable name which is email
underscore id
now we need to store the names phone
numbers and email ids into an excel seat
for that we need to create a data table
so i'll search for data table under
activities
let me go ahead and do that
so i'll
choose build data table and drag it
right below
the input dialog box
now this table has to be assigned to a
variable
so let me do that
let me give a variable name as
fetch underscore
data underscore table
similarly the output also will give the
same variable name which is
fetch underscore data underscore table
one thing i need to tell you here is we
change the variable type
so i'll select browse for types
and look for data table
which is system.data
i'll drill down and search for data
table which is this one
click ok
we need to assign the column names to
this data table
so let me now do that
i'll uncheck all this
and select the columns so you will give
the
first column name as name itself
click on ok select one more column
give it as phone number
click ok and then
we need the email address
i'll hit ok
so we are done
so first the data table is created and
then we'll write this data to an excel
file
after that we need to create rows for
the data table
for that i will search for row
under activities i'll search for row
and i'll select
add row i'll select add
data row
i'll place it right below where we have
created all the variables
now i want to add a row for the name
phone number and email address
so under input i'll select
array row i'll expand this and within
curly braces
i'll give my variable names
so those would be name
give a comma and then
phone underscore number
comma email
underscore id
click ok
i made a mistake it should be within
curly braces
okay now to tell the table to which it
should write the rows to
we need to assign under the data table
name
so under data table i'll give
fetch underscore data underscore table
for every iteration a record will be
added to the table
then we need to rephrase the page to
extract the next set of information
so for that i will add another activity
called click
and drop it right below the add data row
so under activities i'll search for
click and i'll select
mouse click and i'll drop it
right below this one
now we need to indicate where do we want
to click from the browser
so click on this
go on top and
select generate so we want to click on
generate
next i will write the data to a csv file
so i'll search for write csv under
activities
and i'll drop it towards the
end of the sequence right here
now you need to give the location where
you want to place this file on your
system
and give the source from where it will
take the information
so let's give the location where you
want to place this file
i'll place it on my desktop itself i'll
name this as
fetch save it
and for the source
i'll give patch underscore data
underscore table
we are all set now let's run it
so under debug file i'll select
run file
i'll enter the number of records
so let me fetch 10 records click on ok
now this might take some time
i believe it has run successfully now
let me check for my csv file
that should ideally be on my desktop
there you go so we have the csv file let
me open it
you can see it has extracted
10 rows of data and three columns
namely name of the person the phone
number and the email address
so we are done with the first task of
automatically generating data from a
website
the next task is to send this file over
email
now to send an email you need the smtp
activity
so under activities i'll search for
smtp
i'll drag it right below here
now we need to configure this
i'll be actually sending this email from
someone else's email id
to my email id so under 2
i'll give my email address which is
within quotes i'll type abhijit dot
simplylearn.net
i'll give a subject as
automatic
data extraction
under body i'll give something like hi
please find a test now
we have to attach the file
we have to give the location of the file
here so
let me go to properties
and i'll select this
cancel
paste this here followed by
the file name which is fetch
dot csv
i'll click on ok
after that
i have to give the host port number
which is 465
and the
and the server name
which is smtp.gmail.com
under log on i'll give the sender's
email id
i have to give the password as well
under the receiver it's my email id
which is abig.biswal.simplyloan.net
for the sender i'll give the email ids
in my dot
despander simplylearn.net
and i'll give a dummy name chinmay
so we are almost done let me now go to
debug file
and run this
it is asking to enter the number of
records i will give
5 click on ok
this will take some time so let's just
wait
so we have successfully run our program
now let me check my inbox if i have got
any mail from
chinmay so there you go
i've got this email and below you can
see
the fetch.csv file attached and it has
five rows
what is ui path orchestrator
uipath orchestrator is a web application
that allows you to orchestrate the
execution of repetitive business process
by uipath robots orchestrator
manages the creation monitoring
scheduling
and controlling of automated bots and
process
it serves as a point of integration for
third-party solutions and applications
it's a centralized forum for managing
and controlling
all software boards it can manage the
entire robot fleet let's look at the
orchestrated capabilities
provisioning provisioning establishes
and maintains the connection between the
robots and the web application
deployment deployment ensures that the
correct package versions are delivered
to the assigned robots for execution
configuration configuration looks after
the maintenance and delivery of the
robot environments and process
configuration
queues queues ensures that the workload
is distributed automatically across
robots monitoring monitoring manages
user permissions and keeps track of
robot recognition details
logging logging logs are stored and
indexed in a sql database
interconnectivity interconnectivity
functions as a centralized contact point
for third-party solutions or
applications
let's look at the orchestrator use cases
the strength of uipath orchestrator
comes from its ability to control the
entire robot fleet
let's look at the different use cases
the first is attended this type of robot
is activated by user events
and operates at the same workstation as
a human
orchestrator is used with attended
robots to provide a centralized process
deployment
and logging medium unattended
in virtual environments robots can run
unattended and automate a variety of
process
the orchestrator is in charge of remote
execution
control scheduling and support for work
use in addition to the attended robot
capabilities
studio or studio x they have unattended
robot capabilities
but it should only be used to connect
your studio or studio x
to the orchestrator for creation
purposes
non-production robots are similar to
unattended robots
but they can only be used for research
and development
attended unattended non-production
studio
and studio x robots can all be operated
from a single location
let's look at the orchestrator user
interface
dashboard enables us to see charts and
statistics
illustrating usage information for all
the orchestrator components like
process assets queues schedules
robots jobs and transactions
let's look at the tenant context to view
and control the tenant level entities in
your orchestrator
pick tenant from the sidebar menu with
only one instance of the orchestrator
multi-tenancy allows you to isolate data
these features help you to automate
various departments within your
organization
while also ensuring that orchestrated
data is approved according to your
preferences
please bear in mind that all of the
information is contained in this same
database
let's look at the components one by one
robots a robot is an execution host
that runs ui pass studio process you can
add robots
edit them display the status and license
state
adjust the environment they are assigned
to and change the runtime settings on
the robots tab
you can also see the logs that a single
robot has created
process can be downloaded and executed
automatically by robots using custom
settings
while building or editing a robot you
can configure automatic process
downloading
logging level font smoothing and
resolution in the settings tab
folders folders give you a
fine grain control over automation and
their associated organizations
as well as staff through the entire
organization
in the orchestrator there are two types
of folders
classic and modern classic folders
functionality
is allowed by default while modern
folders functionality
must be enabled by the host or the
tenant administrator
users a user is an individual with
access dependent capabilities
whose view and control of the
orchestrator are determined by the
access rights granting
users can be developed and managed
either locally in the orchestrator
or an external directory
roles in orchestrator the roles tab
help you to handle user permissions the
orchestrator view
that a consumer has is defined by the
role they have been assigned
a function allows you to control view
edit
create and delete permissions on all
orchestrator pages and modules
machines a machine page allows you to
provision
and control machines in preparation for
registering robots
with the orchestrator it lists all of
the machines that are currently in
operation as well as their forms it
allows you to create your computer
whether it's standard or a template
packages all projects published from ui
patch studio
and those manually imported are
displayed on the packages tab
you can display all available versions
of any package on the packages tab
as well as the status claims and release
notes if they are available
ml skills ml skills retrieves and
request
machine learning skills from the ai
fabric service
it authenticates the robot that is
running the machine learning skills
audit the audit page shows the audit
trail
for all acts taken by orchestrator
entities
several criteria including component
user action and time can be used to
filter the data
on the audit page credential stores
a credential store is named location
inside a safe store
such as cyberark where you can get robot
credentials
and credential assets when you need them
at the tenant stage
orchestrator encourages the users of
several credential stores
webhooks webhooks make it easier to
integrate your uipath automation
with the rest of your app ecosystem
you can subscribe to the orchestrator
events and have them
sent to the external dcm bpm or crm
solutions
to notify various users about the new
queue items
that can be processed cause failures or
process
updates license
robot licensing is available both at the
host and the tenant level
in the orchestrator on the license list
this enables you to shorten your
deployment time and handle activation
from a single location
within a single click you can trigger
renew
delete and delegate licenses
alerts notifications for robots
queue objects triggers tasks procedures
and activities are shown on the alerts
tab
you will receive updates from all of
your folders on this tab
and you will not be able to choose more
granular options
alerts are sent in real time and can be
categorized as
info success warn error or fatal
settings you can adjust various settings
on the settings tab
including the time zone email warning
information
account information package feeds and
interactive authentication
now let us look with respect to the
folder context from the sidebar menu
pick any available folder to view and
control the entities within that folder
automations contains the following tabs
process jobs triggers and locks
the process page allows you to build new
process from uploaded packages
manage existing process and keep all of
your process
up to date with the latest package
versions this allows you to spread
packages through the entire organization
users and robots and execute process
more quickly from the jobs task
jobs on a uipath robot a job represents
the execution of a procedure the
execution of a job
can be started in either attended or
unattended mode
on attended robots you can't run a job
from the orchestrator
and they can't run under a locked
computer
triggers triggers allow you to run jobs
in a predefined sequence
at predetermined intervals and if new
products are added to your queues
logs the locks page shows you all of the
robot locks
in all of the folders you have access to
to access the locks tab you must have
view permission on the locks
locks are kept in the local database if
the orchestrator
is in accessible monitoring monitoring
contains the following tabs
machines process queues and sla
machines displays information about all
the existing run times
on an aggregate basis and allows you to
check the overall health
of each runtime process the process page
allows you to build new process from the
uploaded packages
managing existing process and keep all
of your process
up to date queues a queue is a storage
container that can accommodate an
infinite number of objects
multiple types of data such as invoice
information or customer information
may be stored in queue objects other
systems such as sap
or salesforce can be used to process
this data
by default the data stored in and output
from the queue items is in free form
sla displays sla and risk sla
information
for all queues in the current folder
with sla predictions allowed
this allows you to determine if the
newly added queue items
will be processed on time and if so what
resources you will need to devote to
ensure that their sla is not violated
when the sla is in danger of not being
reached you will be adequately informed
so that you can make the required
changes
queues use contains the following tabs
queues and review request
in the queues pages click on the review
request tab
to show revision request the page shows
items in different queues
that have been allocated for revision
assets assets are usually shared
variables or credentials
that can be used through several
automation projects
they allow you to store unique
information that the robots can easily
access
storage buckets rpa developers may use
storage buckets
to provide a per folder storage solution
when building automation projects
the storage buckets page shows you your
current bucket configuration
and allows you to build as many new
storage buckets as you need
testing testing contains the following
tabs
test sets test cases test execution
test schedules and test data queues
test said a test set is a collection of
any number of individual test cases
each intended to serve a specific
function
the test sets page list of view
currently available test sets and allows
you to build new tests
updating existing ones and run them
test cases the test cases page shows all
of your test cases
from all of your projects and app
versions in one place
these are the test cases that are used
in and to make up your test sets
test executions your previously executed
test sets and their information
are shown on the test execution tab
since test sets are often subject to
change
test executions act as an immutable
record of any given test sets execution
at a given point in time
test schedules allow you to run test a
predetermined intervals
and in a scheduled manner test data
queues
using test data queues you can store and
manage your test data
the test data queue serves as a
container for queue items
that are ready to be consumed via
various activities
the test data queue items are uploaded
or deleted based on the first in first
out concept
action catalogs task catalogs are task
containers
that allow you to categorize your task
using a variety of criteria
the catalog where a task is stored is
defined when the task is created using
studio's build type task
operation in orchestrator
the catalog must be specified first if
you mention a catalog that has not been
generated in the orchestrator
the task is created in orchestrator
without a catalog
settings setting contains two tabs
permissions and machine permission a
user
is an individual with access dependent
capabilities
whose view and control of the
orchestrator are determined by the roles
assigned to them
users may be installed locally in the
orchestrator or an external director
machines you can use the machines page
to provision
and manage system entities which you can
then use to bind uipath robots to the
orchestrator
it lists all of the machines that are
currently in use
as well as the types machines are global
tools
which means they can be accessed from
any folder
let's look at the demo in this demo we
will see
how to connect uipath robot with the
orchestrator
how to run workflow using the
orchestrator
let's go to the browser in the browser
enter platform
this will take you to the uipath.com
website
you have already an account sign in
enter the password
click on sign meanwhile
open the ui path assistant so this is
the uipath assistant
so uipath robot is a kind of
representative
which runs the workflow so we create a
workflow in the ui path studio then we
upload it on the cloud orchestrator
then we configure different robots to
run this workflow
now that we have logged in to the
orchestrator
go to the admin
so you need to click here to add tenant
for the ui path community free edition
you can
add only one tenant so i have already
created an internet
so this option is disabled for me
so when you click on the add tenant for
the first type the tenant window will be
displayed
then fill the tenant name password and
confirm the password
and it will ask you for name surname and
email address which is optional
so after filling the details click on
provision the tenant and tenant admin
are created and displayed in the tenants
page
so as you can see the tenant is created
there is an option here users and groups
you can go to the users
and you can see the different users so
this is my user
this is me now you can go to the groups
and see the different groups allocated
and their licenses
so now that we have created a tenant
i have named it an entire segment let's
open it
meanwhile you can open uipath assistant
open uipath assistant this is the uipath
robot
there are two different ways to connect
robot to the orchestrator
one is signing in the uipath assistant
it will take the token from the ui path
orchestrator
by user authentication and it will
directly connect machine and the robot
and the other way is to manually connect
so
we'll sign in
enter the password
now you can see here robot is connected
to the orchestrator
so when you sign in the robot will get
connected to the orchestrator
you can go here in the preferences
go to the orchestrator settings and you
can see connected and licensed
so let's go to the orchestrator
in the orchestrator go to the tenant
context
and here you can see the robot is
connected
it's enabled if you go to the machines
you can see the machine is also
connected
so you can see here
there is an unattended robot here
so to get this unattended robot what you
have to do is
go to the users
select the user which you are using this
is my username
go to edit
and here you should enable this
unattended robot enable this option and
enter the username
to get the username you can open the
command prompt and
enter who am i so you will get the
username copy paste the username
enter the password and click on update
and the unattended robot will get
created
so that is how you create the unattended
robot
now that we have connected robot to the
orchestrator
let's open the ui patch studio we'll
create a workflow
and then we'll run it using the robot
so now we have opened the uipath studio
let's open a blank process
after opening the uipath studio click on
open main workflow
first we'll drag and drop a sequence
then we need a input dialog box we'll
drag and drop
input dialog box enter our title
let's say we'll enter it as uipath
orchestrator
enter the input label we'll enter it as
enter your name
let the input type b as text box let's
create a variable say we'll name it as
name and let the variable type be string
and the scope is in the sequence score
we have created the variable so the
value entered should be
the variable here
now we'll drag and drop message box
from this set should be displayed
so you enter a caption for the message
say bait
welcome
and enter the text let's say
hi
and we need to concatenate it with the
variable names
will say thanks for watching
this video
so here we go we have created a workflow
now we need to publish this in the
orchestrator
so you can see our option here called
publish click on the publish button
so you can see the package name the
version
the new version and all the other things
click on the publish button
so the workflow is successfully
published so the name is blank process
three and version is one point zero
point sixty
so let's go to the orchestrator
in orchestrator go to the my workflow
folder context in this go to my packages
if you go here you can see refresh it
so here you can see blank process three
so process
what we did now it was published three
minutes ago
let's go to the process and the version
what we published was 1.0.16
so the name was blank process 3.
let's start the job you can
change the job priority we'll keep it as
normal the other things is default the
process name and the job type
let's let execute this process one time
click on start
as you can see command send for blank
process 3
so here you can see it is getting run
here you can see it is asking for uipath
orchestrator what we entered title and
enter your name
let's enter some names say sam
click ok so hi sam thanks for watching
this video
there you go the message has been
displayed like normally in ui patch
studio we click on the run button
and run the workflow but here we have
published it in the orchestrator
and through the orchestrator through the
robot we are
running it and the message is displayed
what is
framework and its purpose
the framework is intended to serve as a
blueprint for users to create process
that provide at a bare minimum a way to
store
interpret and easily change project
configuration data
as well as robot exception handling
scheme and event logging
for all exceptions and related
transaction information
the system locks messages at each
relevant stage
in the process of resolving a business
transaction
and sends those logs to the orchestrator
server
this in turn can be linked to the elk
stack which is elasticsearch
log stack and kibana platform which
allows for data storage
and a variety of different ways to
represent the data
the purpose of our framework is to
resolve a set of business transaction
a transaction is a small amount of data
and the steps needed to process
it to complete a segment of business
process a process
that reads a single email from a mailbox
and extracts data from it is a good
example
what is a business process
the sum of actions by which the data
required for a series of transactions
is collected processed and input into or
out of an it resource
is referred to as a business process we
can classify business process
into three groups based on the steps
involved and how they are repeated
linear the steps of linear process are
only done once
and if different data needs to be
processed the automation must be run
again iterative the steps of iterative
process
are repeated several times but different
data items are used every time
transactional transactional systems like
iterative process
have steps that replicate several times
over various data objects
what is re framework
the robotic enterprise framework is a
state machine based project template
the template includes several ready to
use state containers
for launching applications retrieving
data processing it and closing the
transaction
these states are linked together by a
series of transactions
that cover almost every requirement in a
typical automation scenario
several workflows have been triggered
each of which deals with a different
aspect of project
it's designed to incorporate all of the
industry's best practices
for logging exception management
application
initialization and other areas
showing it to handle even the most
complex business situations
let's look at the features of re
framework the three features are
settings
logging and business application
exception
settings during the initialization phase
of several process
some configuration settings and
configuration values are frequently read
like urls to the web application
orchestrator queue names
and default logging messages the
reframework maintains the track of this
information
by reading it from a configuration file
and storing it in a different dictionary
object shared by all states
instead of updating workflows directly
this provides a simple way to manage
projects by adjusting values in the
configuration file
logging the built-in locking mechanism
is another helpful feature of re
framework a majority of system workflows
use log message activities to output
information
about what is happening at each stage of
execution
this can be used to not only identify
problems and aid in the debugging
process
but also to generate visualization and
reports
about the process execution like how
many invoices are handled every day
how many failures occur and what are the
critical causes of this failure
business and application execution
there may be conditions that occur
during the execution of most process
that are not part of the usual execution
flow and must be resolved to achieve
more efficient automation
if the issue can be resolved by
restarting application
the framework will do so automatically
and attempt to process the transaction
again
such exceptions are known as application
exception
if the issue is with the data or an
underlying business requirement
the system skips the transaction and
moves to the next
such exception are known as business
exception
let's look at the re framework
architecture
the rb framework is implemented as a
state machine
which is a form of workflow with two
advantageous characteristics
states and transitions actions to be
taken
in response to the stated input are
described by states transitions
that switch the execution from one state
to another based on the results of the
state
there are four key states in re
framework that is
initial state get transaction data
process transaction and end process
initial state initialization this is the
point at which the procedure begins
it's an event where the process
initializes the settings
and runs application test to ensure that
all of the prerequisites for the process
start are met
so initialization transitions so there
are two transition
system exception and successful when
system exception
when a system error is not nothing it
gets transition to the end process
if we have an application exception
during the initialization phase
we don't have enough details to start
the process as a result
we are going to the end process state to
wrap it up
successful when a system error is
nothing it gets transition to get
transaction data
if during the initialization we have no
error then we go to the
get transaction data the next state is
the get transaction state
this date retrieves the next transaction
object this can be a queue item or a
collection item
transaction items are queue items by
default
but this can be modified to meet your
needs this is also the state
where the developer can set the
condition to exit the state
when there are no items to process get
transaction data transitions there are
two transitions
no data and new transaction
no data if the transaction item is
nothing then
we are at the end of our data collection
so we go to the end process
new transaction data if the transaction
item contains data then we process it
next state is the process transaction
state
the process transaction state for the
transaction item obtained in the
previous step
it performs actions and applies logic in
various application
if a transaction item has been processed
the process moves on to the next
transaction item that is available
so there are three process transaction
transitions
success business exception and system
exception
in success if the condition is business
rule exception
is nothing and system error is nothing
then the transition to get transaction
data
if there is a business rule exception it
is logged and we move on to the next
transition
business exception if the business rule
exception is not nothing
then it gets transition to get
transaction data
if we have a business rule exception we
log it and move to the next transaction
by going to the get transaction data
state
system exception if we have an
application exception
we close all programs kill them if they
fail to complete
take a screenshot at the moment the
exception happened and go to init
where we re-initialize our working
environment and begin a new
form of transaction that has failed and
finally we have the end process date
the procedure is completed and the
application opened during the automation
are closed in the end process state
since this is the last state the final
state there are no transition available
in the end process state we'll explore
each one of the
states in detail in the demo let's see
the demo now
in this demo we will see how to dispatch
data from the excel file
then we will create queue items and
process these items
and then we will understand the working
of each state in the robotic enterprise
framework in detail
so let's get started first we'll go to
the orchestrator and create a queue
enter cloud platform dot
ui
sign up then go to the orchestrator
the tenant which you have created
select the folder context go to the
folder context
and you can see queues here go to the
queues
and you can see a option to add here
click on
add and enter a queue name
[Music]
i'll enter it as ref enter any
description if you want
give unique reference yes and
act and you can see
a queue has been added so you can add an
asset
as well to add an asset you can go to
add
click here add and enter the asset name
[Music]
and select the type whatever is required
say boolean
and by default be it as false and create
so this is how you create an asset so
let's go to the ui path studio so what
we are
basically doing is we are building two
process
one to feed a queue in the orchestrator
that is a dispatcher process
and one to process transaction from the
queue that is using the robotic
enterprise framework
so in dispatcher process what we do is
we get entries from an excel file
and add them as a queue items in the
orchestrator
we have already created a queue we
started project
as sequence and added a try catch we
started with the sequence
added a try catch activity in the try
block
we used a retransactivity to read first
10 lines
from a1 to c11 from an excel file and
store them in a newly created data
table variable we used for each row
to loop through the rows of the data
table variable and add each of them in a
queue using the add queue item activity
then we used a log message we use log
message activity
to lock the fact that the dispatching
process was successful
that is how we created the dispatcher
process
now we will create a performer
using robotic enterprise framework what
it does is we get titles from the queue
and processes
so
[Music]
in the dispatcher process let's go to
the initialization
state first
so we'll understand initialization state
in detail
so the entire index block is kept inside
the try catch
if you go to the documents here and if
you go to the data folder
you can see a config file here
so config file this is the file we use
in the init state
it has three sheets settings constants
and assets you can give
any values whatever you want for maximum
retry number
the value should be zero when you are
working with your orchestrator queues
the value should be
zero so this config file is stored in
the
data folder
and it has three sheets settings
constants and assets
this is the queue name process abc let's
get back to the
framework
so we are initializing system error if
the error is nothing it will go to the
next state
if first run read local configuration
file
you can see by default there are many
variables created
you should know them and utilize them
whenever required
the config variable the value type is
dictionary type
config is nothing if you go here
you can see here config is nothing
initially there is no value so initially
config is nothing then it will input
init all settings workflow
let's open this first run
so it will invoke init all settings
workflow
to see this workflow click on open
workflow
it has three arguments
it has three arguments in config file in
config sheets
and out config file this is of
type string type string and out config
is of type digital
and direction this is a both our input
and this is
out
let's open the workflow and understand
so basically what this workflow does is
this workflow outputs setting dictionary
with the key value
pairs to be used in the project settings
are referred from the local config file
and then fetched from the orchestrator
assets assets will overwrite the config
file settings
in it all settings workflow invoked to
initialize all settings
and data for application and process use
in this part the setting constant
and assets in the config file from the
data folder are read
in the initialize all settings so
let's go back the orchestrator queue
name
from the from the configuration file in
the argument case
is specified and it provides a backward
compatibility
next we have invoke kill process
if we go to the arguments here we can
see the
orchestrator queue name you can assign a
queue name here if you have created a
queue
so input kill process
next we have invoke kill process it is a
logging activity called killing process
depending on the project you can add
active it is a logging activity
called killing process depending on the
project you can add activities
and add log fields in add log fields if
you want to add any details in the log
file
then you can do it using all log fields
init all applications
workflow in this workflow invoke to open
apps and check the status credentials
and
so on and that there are two transitions
in this when it is
successful it gets transition to get
transaction data
when there is a system exception it goes
to the end process
so so in short what initialization state
does is
at the end of this workflow that is the
initialization state it reads the config
file
and stores the key and value inside the
dictionary that is the out config
what config dictionary variable has all
config excel file data
let's see the get transaction data
when you are in the orchestrator and you
want to immediately stop a java for some
reason when the job is stopped
this activity gets activated there is a
variable
created should stop if
it's a boolean variable by default it's
false when it gets activated the value
becomes
yes then it will go to the log stop
message as stop process requested
and it will end the process when the
transaction
item is nothing else it will go to the
try get transaction data
here it has seven arguments
and let's see the workflow invoke get
transaction data workflow
click on open workflow
it gets the data from the spreadsheets
databases email
web api or ui path server use if no new
data items
then set out the transaction item to
nothing
if a new transaction item is retrieved
then it gets the additional information
about it it gives the condition
where our transaction item is not
nothing then it will add the transaction
information to the log fields
it is about the get transaction data
workflow
in process transaction state the process
is a sequence with a try catch activity
set to catch both system exceptions and
business exceptions
inside the tie block the process
transaction workflow
invoked that has simple process like to
attach the ui demo application
and three type into activities to fill
in and
click accept button
and if you see look at the transitions
it has three transition
system exception whose destination is
the initialization state
business exception goes back to the get
transaction data
and success it goes to the get
transaction data
finally the end process state where the
applications
is closed what is web automation
the concept of allowing software robots
to do predefined actions
activities and procedures on a web
browser or an online application
is known as web automation web
automation
can help with the operations like form
filling
screen scraping data extraction and
transfer across
apps websites and testing and periodic
report preparation
features of web automation in uipath
uipath is compatible with all webs
it is compatible with html ajax
java silverlight and pdf
automated data entry data entry from an
excel spreadsheet to website can be
automated in ui path
it provides simple web testing without
any programming knowledge
uipath helps in designing a valid test
no coding is required we can create
automation
with a simple to use graphical workflow
designer
playback precision uipath provides 100
playback precision
web automation can be done regardless of
the browser version
screen position or size how does web
automation work in uipath
a built-in recorder in uipath web
automation
can read and implement web-based
activities
it uses attributes to identify web items
and manipulates them accurately while
keeping up with page changes
it can be used with any website no
matter how sophisticated
and can be installed remotely through
the network
the graphical workflow editor is simple
to use
and does not require any coding
knowledge it's something that any user
with no programming experience can do
you save time and money by automating
web-based workflows with ui path
let's look at the demo so in this demo
we will scrape data from the simply
learns website
we'll go to simply learns website so
consider a scenario
where a customer wants to know details
about a particular course
suppose if i want to know all the ui
path related resources that are present
on the website
so i'll search as ui path
and i'll select all free resources that
are available on the website
so here you can see there are 27 results
27 free resources available on the
simply lens website
so i'll scrape all of this data so using
data scraping option in uipath
i'll scrape the resource name along with
the type
whether it's an article or video
tutorial and along with that i'll scrape
the url
so i'll scrape all these three things
and copy it in the excel sheet
and the excel sheet over and mail i'll
send it to the customer
so let's get started so let's jump into
uipath studio
and get started with the demo so let's
create a new
flowchart we'll name the flowchart as
web automation since we are
showing this demo under web automation
so a new flowchart is created so in this
flowchart we will
drag and drop a sequence activity
right click
right click and select as set as start
node
so open the sequence and drag and drop
and open browser activity
in the open browser activity select the
browser type
select the whichever browser you want
i'll select chrome
and one more thing you need to do is
go to home go to tools and install the
ui path extensions click on chrome
and if you want to continue installing
ui path extension for chrome please
close all your chrome process then click
on ok
so then click on ok and your ui path
extension
for chrome will get installed so since i
have already installed i'll click on
cancel
when after installing when you open
chrome so your screen will look like
this
so where you have to enable the
extension click on enabling
extension and the chrome extension will
be installed in your
device
okay so let's come back to uipath studio
so select the open browser select the
browser where you want to get it
installed
so let's create a variable here
let's create a variable as website url
let's go to variable and enter the url
so let's go to the
simply learns website
and copy the url
once the url is copied so this open
browser
activity is a container that enables you
to open a browser
at a specified url and execute multiple
activities within it
so we have selected the open browser so
inside the open browser activity
we will drag and drop maximize window
activity
maximize window it maximizes the
indicated window
so after this next we need to drag and
drop type into activity
so we'll drag and drop type into
activity
bring it outside
bring it outside the open browser
indicate on the screen the first thing
is we need to select the search bar
so we'll select the search bar and what
we are entering here is ui paths since
we are searching for ui path course
so enter ui path and after entering
uipath
we need to click on enter so we need to
enter
to search the uipath related resources
so click on this
plus button and select the enter
option select
enter so
separate this concatenate it
okay so this is done so once
in the browser after entering ui part
the next thing we need to do is click on
this free resources
click on this all option check this box
so for that what we have to do is
search for click option click activity
and select this click activity
indicate on screen and select
this click
so this is done next thing what we need
to do is
when we click here on all we find 27
results
so when we do it automatically when the
bot does is
when the robot does this thing it does
not go down
and refresh all the results what it does
is
when it opens this page without loading
the
below results how much our results are
available
some 10 results it will copy only those
10 results
it will not refresh and copy the results
which are below
so for that what we have to do is we
will go to ui patch studio
we will select drag and drop one more
type into
activity and will indicate
on screen we'll scroll down
till the bottom
and we'll simply select this blank
screen just because
so that the every time the robot comes
into this page
it goes till the bottom and copies all
the results that is why
we select simply a blank screen here and
it is showing an error we have to enter
something here so we'll select a
command say since we are scrolling it
down we'll select down
and this much is done so go back to the
flowchart
which we have created automation and
we'll drag and drop a new sequence
so till here it's done where we are
opening the simply lunch website and
searching for ui path
next we what we'll do is we will
scrape the data so we'll rename it as
data scraping
we'll open this sequence so data
scraping is something where we extract
structured data from a browser
application or a document to a data
table
so we'll click on data scripting so
we'll open the browser
so we have opened the browser now we'll
select the data which we want to extract
so click on next
scroll up
so first we'll select the resource name
so we'll select
top ui path interview questions to
create a pattern
we need to indicate a similar field
preferably the last in the collection
or the second one so what we'll do is
we'll select the second one
and we can create a column and we'll
name the column
as resources
if you want you can take the url we'll
take the url before that
we'll take the type so these are the
resources
for 27 resources
if the maximum number of results it will
go to is 100 if we enter 100 year
if you want more than 100 you can remove
this 100 and keep it as 0
so it will select all 0 for all
so after this will extract correlated
data
this time we will extract the type
whether it's an article
or it's the video tutorial click on
article
and indicate the similar field for the
next one we'll select video tutorial
so this column will name it as time
and we will extract the url of each
resource
and we will name the column as say
link links okay
next and we are done
so enter on finish
is data spanning multiple pages in
our case there is no multiple pages
there is only one page
in case if there are multiple pages you
can
click on yes here press s to indicate it
scroll down
and select the next pages but since in
this page
there is only one page so we'll click on
no
okay this much is done we have script
data so after the data scraping is done
we want to
copy the script data into an excel sheet
so
to copy it in the excel sheet we need
excel application scope
so we'll search for excel application
scope activity
so excel application scope activity
opens an excel workbook
providing a scope for excel activities
when this activity ends
the workbook and excel applications are
closed if the specified file does not
exist
a new excel file is created so for this
excel application scope so we'll go to
desktop go to new
and create a new microsoft excel
worksheet
we'll name it as uipath
ui part details
so we have created a file
we will go back to the uipath studio
now we will select the file which we had
created
we'll go to desktop and select the file
uipath details
and we'll click on open next we will
drag and drop right range activity
we'll search for
right range activity bring it inside the
do
and by default it is sheet1 and a1
so right range activity writes the data
from a data table in a spreadsheet
starting from the cell if the starting
cell isn't specified the writing begins
at a1 cell
so once that is done now we need to
enter the variable that is extract data
table variable which we extracted here
that is this variable extract data table
you need to enter this variable
go here and search for
extract data table variable so this much
is done we have scraped data from the
simply lens website
then using the pixel application scope
we have written the data in the
excel sheet so let's run till here and
see whether it's scraping the data
and writing in the excel sheet so
we'll save it and click on run
so let's see we'll close this
here you can see it's opening the simply
lens website
entering ui path oops we have made an
error
okay let's go and let's stop here
so we had made an error here the bracket
was missing
that is why now we have corrected it
let's save and
run for that close this
it's opening the simply lunch website it
will enter ui path
select all the free resources then it
will
copy this in the excel sheet you can see
it's copying
so let's open the excel worksheet which
we created
and let's check if it has copied so you
can see in the excel file which we had
created
the data has been scraped and copied
here in the first column
it is the course name or the resource
name which we had copied
in the second column it is the type
whether it is an article or video
tutorial
in the third column it is the url there
are no
headers here right we can give the
headers
so we'll go to the uipath studio
and if you click on excel application
scope or
write range here you can see add headers
so click here and the headers will be
added in the excel sheet
so this much is done now next step is
we need to send this excel file over and
mail
so to send this excel file over and mail
let's go to activities let's drag and
drop a new sequence
we'll use a separate sequence to send
the activities over our mail
sorry not here
we will connect this will name this
activity
as main since we are
sending it our mail open this sequence
the first activity we need here is get
password activity
so search for get password
drag and drop it get password activity
encrypts a password by associating it
with the current user
only workflows running under the current
user context can decrypt the password
so go to the password and enter your
email id password
and in the result create a new variable
and store the password in a variable so
that your
password is encrypted and name the
variable as
pass word short form something password
and next activity we need is send smtp
mail message
so double click on send smtp mail
message
so this activity basically sends an
email message by using the smtp protocol
so go to the port and enter the port
which is
587 and go to the server
and enter the server smtp.gmail.com
and enter the email id to which you want
to
send the mail
enter the password the password variable
which we had created
enter that and enter the email id here
as well
so enter the subject of the mail what
you
what you want the subject to be so i'll
name it as
course details
and enter the body so i'll enter a
simple
hello hello
here are the details
okay so there is a prerequisite for this
uh you have to to receive for to send an
email you have to go to your google
account that is the email account
security option and there you have to
turn on
secured access go to the option called
secured access and turn it on
okay next we need to attach the file the
file which we want to send it over and
mail attach the file in which we had
scraped the data from the simply lens
website
so let's go to web automation
the previous sequence and copy the file
path from the excel application scroll
so we'll copy this file path
and go back
in the attach file
we will paste this path
remove one double quote
click on ok next we will drag and drop a
message box
just for like our reference to show a
message so that the
process is completed so we'll enter a
simple message in the message box like
the course details have been made
successfully
so let me correct this spelling
details okay
so now there are no errors so now the
project is complete
so what i have done is i have taken a
flowchart in the flowchart i have taken
a first sequence
in this sequence i am opening the
browser the simply learns
browser i'm maximizing it then i am
not type using the type into activity i
am
recording the search bar in the search
bar i'm entering the ui path and
clicking on enter so after clicking on
enter i'll select the
all option where i'll select all the
resources
in the first sequence then in the second
sequence i'm scraping the data
in scraping data option i'll scrape the
data i'll escape the course name the
type and the url
then in the excel application scope i'll
copy
all the scrape data in an excel file so
i'll use an excel application scope i
have created a file
so in that file i'll write the script
data
in the second sequence then finally in
the third sequence
i am using the get password activity and
send smtp
mail message and i'm sending it over an
email
i'm sending the excel file as an
attachment with an email
to the customer this message box
simply indicates that the mail has been
successfully
sent okay now let me save
and click on run so i'll close the
previous browser let me save
and click on run web automation
execution is started it is going to the
browser
went to simply learn website
search for ui path click on all
resources
and it's copying the resources in an
excel sheet
after copying the resource in an excel
sheet it is sending over an email
so it has sent over an email and the
message has been displayed
the course details have been
successfully mail let me go to my
email inbox and check whether i have
received it
so let me click on course it has been
made successfully
let me refresh and here you can see i
have received
the mail let me open this file
so here you can see i have received the
file which consists of resources the
type and the
link what is excel automation
excel automation is a task automation
involving excel files studio x
enables the creation of automation
project involving various types of data
from an excel
file using various specialized
activities
to create an excel automation we must
use excel file resource
when creating a new project that
includes excel
an excel file must be specified within
it so that all of the subsequent
actions can access the data contained
within that file
why use an excel automation uipath
allows you to automate excel in various
ways
such as excel application scope
activities
and workbook activities excel automation
simplifies your application by
performing tasks such as formatting
cells updating values and running macros
automatically
excel task in automated process can also
be integrated
with several other functions across the
enterprise using an rpa solution
the benefit of excel automation in
general
is that it can save people many are
spent manually completing tasks
advantages of excel automation
productivity excel automation provides
higher production rates
and increased productivity efficiency
some of the functions of excel can
easily create
automated tasks and custom logic with
functions like macros
macros are an excellent way to save time
on predictable
repetitive task hence excel automation
is efficient
better product quality excel automation
improves quality in several ways
including eliminating human error
increasing consistency and accuracy
the ability to create more complex
projects and the detection of mistakes
along the way
improved safety excel allows you to
protect your work
whether it's to prevent someone from
opening a workbook without a password
to grant read-only access to a workbook
or to simply
preserve a worksheet so you don't delete
any data
reduce labor excel automation will
perform all the repetitive tasks more
accurately and productively than humans
thus reduces labor reduced lead time
a lead time is the amount of time that
elapses between the start and finish of
a process
excel automation reduces the lead time
let's look how to install an excel
package
let's jump into the uipath studio to
install an excel package
go to the manage packages
you can see the packages that are
installed go to all packages
and search for uipath excel activities
by default an updated version will be
installed if the excel package is not
installed
you can install it from here so in my
device
this activity is already installed
this is the place from where you can
install any
activities or any packages
let's see some of the commonly used
excel activities
these are some of the commonly used
excel activities
redrain select range save workbook
autofill range copy paste
range insert and delete columns so
insert
inserting a column at the specified
location in a sheet
or a table or a range and to delete a
column
you can delete it from a specified range
or the table
there are filters filter table so what
filters does is you can use the filter
action
to create a filter in a range table or a
sheet based on the values in a single
column
we also have vlookup vlookup which
stands for vertical lookup
is an excel feature that when enabled
searches and retrieves data from a
specified column
we will explore all of these activities
in the demo section
in detail let's look at the demo
in this demo we have an excel sheet that
has a record of covet cases
in five states of india in 2021
so we will create an excel automation to
represent the number of cases
in charge
it's easy to understand looking at the
charts
rather than looking at the huge numbers
then we will upload the file on the
drive so
let's jump into the ui path studio and
get started
this is the excel file which i have
created it has
all the number of cases in this five
states
in the year 2021 the month of jan feb
march and april all this record i have
taken it from a website called
prsindia dot org
so i have two sheets sheet1 and sheet2
so let's jump into the ui path studio
to start off with the demo we need to
have the three packages
installed one is the uipath
excel activities package the other one
is uipath gsu.activities
this activity this package is used for
drive topload on the drive then
the other package is balareva excel
activities
this package is used for bar graph
and pie chart
so after installing these three
packages we'll get started
so let's create a new sequence
name it as sequence 2
so first we'll drag and drop an excel
application scope
so excel application scope what it does
is
it opens an excel workbook and sets the
scope for excel activities
when this activity is completed the
specified workbook and the excel
applications
are closed when the workbook application
variable is specified in the output
workbook activities field the
spreadsheet is not closed
after this drag and drop create table
activity
so by default we have sheet1 and
enter the range so the range is
in this excel sheet ranges from a1
to f5 so enter the range
for this we need to enter the
file path so we'll select the file
so we have selected the file we have
entered the
enter the table name say
number of cases
[Music]
so once this much is done next we'll
drag and drop a
bar chart
drop it outside the excel application
scope
and select the file path so
select the file
so select the file select this cell
range
that is the same range what we had
entered earlier
a1 to f5
so once that is done if the chart title
say basis
and you can select the chart type
bar stack 3d clustered 3d stand
whatever is required for now we will
select bar
cluster we have many other options to
explore
data label type will keep it
[Music]
in value
so that it shows the value
and select show value
if you want show percentage you can
select percentage
and select show legend and size
you can vary the size accordingly how
much ever you want
so i'll keep the size as
350.
350 you can change the width
so the bar chart is done and you can
enter the sheet which sheet are you
using so it's sheet1
so we will drag and drop pie chart
select the file
similarly enter the options here
enter the cell range the same range
a1 is to f5
show percent will show value
select show value
and select the sheet which you will
select the sheet too
so done so we have completed till here
next we need to upload this on the
google drive
so we'll select this option upload file
select the file
so we have selected the file so select
the destination folder
for that go to your google drive account
so we will go there
so in my drive i have created a folder
called excel automation
so i'll copy this url
till here not the entire properties
and go to your ui patch studio
and paste it in the destination folder
here double quotes
then create a variable and
create a variable as file
oops there is an error we have forgotten
to use a g-suite application
this can be only used inside a g suite
application
so drag and drop a g suite application
and inside g suite application
we'll write this so there is god
so we will run the file now we'll save
it
and
you can see the file is getting
run
so the execution is ended we will
navigate to the drive
so here you can see the file is
successfully uploaded
will open the file
it's working on the graph
here you go here you can see the bar
graph
for the sheet one with the values
number of values and each state wise and
for sheet2
we created a pie chart so here you go
here you can see the question
let's begin by understanding who is an
rpa developer
now generally speaking an rpa developer
is someone who works
cross-functionally with business
operations and business analysts
to create and optimize workflow
processes however this is a relatively
new career path
and many organizations formal titles for
rpa developers differ
now other similar positions may include
titles like process designer or
automation architect
but no matter the title the role of a
successful rpa developer
involves to design develop and implement
rpa systems
in order to automate a business process
an rpa developer will be required to
create workflow diagrams and
strategically document the
implementation
he is also responsible for bug fixes so
coding skills are important
now in order to be a successful rpa
developer you must have the ability to
navigate
various appropriate technologies such as
ui path or automation anywhere
next up is rpa growth projections
now looking at the curve both rpa
software and services
increased by huge amounts between 2016
and 2020 and beyond
according to next day research knowledge
and work automation could have an
economic impact
of about five to seven trillion us
dollars for the year 2025.
it will touch more than 230 million
knowledge workers which constitute up to
nine percent of the global workforce
now any company which is labor intensive
where people are performing high volume
high transaction functions
will boost their capabilities and save
money and time without
you now that we've established that rpa
has a steep growth curve
let's look at the rpa job roles that you
should look out for
we have the rpa developer senior rpa
developer
rpa process architect rp developer
senior consultant
project manager lead developer business
analyst
and rpa data analyst
now these job roles come with specific
responsibilities depending on the
designation
however there are a few common
responsibilities of an rpa developer
let's go ahead and check them out
now the first one is strategic planning
skills now planning is a crucial phase
in any development life cycle
the rpa developer regardless of the
designation should possess the aptitude
to ensure strategic planning
planning includes the design development
and implementation of rpa systems
this also helps streamline the business
next up is strong analytical skills now
to understand the client's requirements
and cater to the needs accordingly
is crucial analytical skills are also
important to predict or identify
potential bugs and errors and rectify
them
now this scale is especially required if
you're involved in the overall
development
next we have strong problem solving
skills now this again is extremely
crucial to predict
any outages and equip the entire unit to
overcome any unforcing interruptions
from the business perspective as well
problem solving skills play a
significant role in ensuring smooth
conduction of tasks
experience in any programming language
such as c c plus plus
python ruby java or dot net is also
important
hands-on experience in rpa tools and
cognitive platforms such as blue prism
automation anywhere ui path open span
etc is necessary communication skills
are pivotal for any organization
the developer should be outspoken and
articulate any new ideas
you should also be confident to raise
concerns and be as transparent as
possible
in the long run this only proves to be
helpful to the organization
lastly we have exposure to sql now
experience with database be it sql or
nosql is highly preferred
it's always an added advantage if you
have the knowledge about accessing and
managing databases
next up we have rpa developer salaries
now the salaries will differ depending
on the location your experience and also
the designation
now in the u.s here are the job salaries
and
the roles according to glassdoor an rpa
developer in the u.s
earns around 76 000 u.s dollars per year
the nrpa developer senior consultant
earns around 99 000 us dollars per year
an rpa process architect earns an
average salary of 95
000 us dollars and the senior rpa
developer earns an average salary of 92
000 us dollars
an rpa project manager earns around 73
000 us dollars per annum
an rpa lead developer earns an average
salary of 99
000 us dollars per annum an rpa business
analyst
earns around 68 000 us dollars per annum
and the data analyst earns around 62 000
us dollars per annum
moving on to india the average salary of
an rpa developer is around 5 lakhs 98
000 rupees that of a senior consultant
a senior rpa developer and an rpa lead
developer is around 14 lakhs per annum
and the average salary of an rpa
business analyst is around 5 lakhs 40
000 rupees
now let me quickly run you through a
sample resume of an rpa developer
now this is just a template and you can
alter it according to your needs
first up is your general information
like name phone number and your email id
then you can give a quick description
about yourself and your strengths you
can also mention the objective as to why
you're applying
and what you're looking for in the
organization
you can include your linkedin profile
link and your github link
one look at your linkedin profile is
enough for anybody to gather all the
information necessary
so make sure that is updated moving on
you could mention your experience
now here you would have to mention the
names of your previous organizations
along with your designation
and the tenure you could also include
your key responsibilities in these
organizations
along with the responsibilities you
could also mention the awards that you
received in your organizations
next up is your educational background
you can mention the university that you
graduated from
and is required that you have a degree
in computer science
you can also go ahead and mention your
gpa
the next section is skills now this is
pretty crucial in the technical skills
section you could mention about
different rpa tools that you worked on
if you're good at a particular
programming language go ahead and
mention that as well
as mentioned earlier any experience in
database management is an added
advantage
if you have any experience go ahead and
mention that moving on to non-technical
skills
you could mention any extracurricular
activities that you're proud of
some soft skills that you feel worth
mentioning can be added in this section
mentioning the languages that you know
can also boost your resume
now given all this it's fundamental that
you do not lie on your resume
all right then with that we conclude
this session i hope and give you a clear
understanding of the subject
uipath assists business in successfully
automating their business process
if you are planning to attend an
interview for an rpa or ui part
developer role
here is a comprehensive list of most
frequently asked ui path interview
questions with answers
what is ui path this question looks
simple
but people most of the time end up
giving wrong definition
uipath is a robotic process automation
tool for large-scale end-to-end
automation
for an accelerated business change it
provides solution for business to
automate routine office activities
it uses a variety of methods to
transform tedious tasks
into automated process what are the
different components in ui
ui path consists of three components
mainly ui path studio
ui patch studio is a user-friendly
interface that allows users to visually
plan
and design various automation process
through diagrams using the drag and drop
functionality
these diagrams are merely a structural
reflection of specific tasks that must
be completed
uipath robot after you have built your
process
the next move is to put into action in
the ui path studio
uipath robots are used to translate the
strategies into tasks which are then
executed
these robots are used to assign various
tasks and carry them out in the same
manner as humans but without human
interference
when given an operation occurs on the
computer they program ui path robots to
begin
executing task automatically
ui path orchestrator the orchestrator is
a web-based application in ui path
it has features for deploying monitoring
scheduling
and controlling automated bots and
process it's a centralized forum for
managing and maintaining all software
bots
what are the different workflows in
uipath
sequences a sequence is a small type of
project
that is best suited for linear process
it enables
developers to transition from one
activity to another easily
they can be reused numerous times
flowchart it can be used for large or
small projects that help in development
of complex business
and connecting activities in a variety
of ways
flowcharts assist in the presentation of
multiple branches of logical operators
state machine a state machine is a
machine that uses a certain number of
states
for automation during execution it will
only change states if an action is
performed on it
let's look at the next question what is
a
uipath robot the robot
is a ui path execution agent allowing
you to run process created in the studio
in order to execute process robots must
be connected to the orchestrator
are licensed locally what are the
different components of uipath robot
service the robot service is the primary
controller for all operations
it communicates with studio the robot
agent and the robot command line
interface
by an inter-process communication
channel to receive and process
information
executor the robot executor is the
component that is directly responsible
for process execution
the robot service creates a robot
executor instance every time a job is
started
command line interface the robot command
line interface is a console application
that starts jobs and waits for their
results
uipath assistant is a tool designed
specifically to improve the user's
interaction with our robots from the
comfort of the desktop
it is where users can easily access
manage and run
automation with a few clicks
what is the difference between attended
and unattended robot
attended robots are supervised robots
that humans operate
they work on the same workstation as a
human user and is triggered by user
events
unattended robots unattended robots
are those that do not require human
supervision to perform
tasks they run in virtual environments
without human control
and can automate any number of process
what are the features of uipath drag and
drop workflow
the uipath user will develop visual
process steps
by dragging and dropping related tasks
onto the graphical workspace
then with the user interface properties
they can transform these process steps
into a visual workflow
users may also use the recorder wizard
in the uipath tool
to build web-based or application
workflow
record and playback the user can use
this function
to record actions and transform them
into an automated process series
inbuilt activities in ui path uipath
comes with over 300 built-in activities
covering a wide range of process
automation and application integrated
design tasks
you can find these activities in
activities pane
which covers most design tasks such as
data extraction data entry and
automation
advanced scraping options scraping data
from web pages
and applications is more accessible with
ui path screen scraping
furthermore the data scraping wizard
helps in the scraping of data with a
repetitive structure
scraping solution works flawlessly with
any program
including dotnet java flash pdf legacy
and sap
high security and robustness you can
create
super smart durable robots with ui path
visual canvas everyone in the company
can use these boards
uipath offers high security auto login
functionality to run the
bots and operates with a locked screen
allowing automated process to run in
complete privacy
what are the different recording options
in ui path
basic recording it focuses on automating
single task and is commonly used to
develop
each activity's complete selector
desktop recording
it can be used for a variety of actions
as well as application development
web recording web recording is a
standard tool for viewing and recording
web activities
citrix recording it is very widely used
for recording stuff like pictures and
virtualized environment automation
what is a manage package in uipath
the package manager functionality allows
to download activities packages
libraries
frameworks wrappers and others and view
and update the ones already installed
for the project
and add and remove it it displays the
list of available packages per feed
and a list of dependencies for the
current project
the manage package windows always opens
with the project dependencies list
how to publish a project in uipath
to publish a project in uipath first
create a new project
then in the design ribbon tab click
publish the publish window
will open in the package properties tab
enter the name for package then click
next
in the publish options tab select the
location where you want to publish your
project
and finally the information dialog box
displays
so let's see a demo how
is it done so let's jump in the ui path
studio
so here we are in uipath studio
let's open our workflow
i'll drag and drop a simple message box
just to show
enter a message say
hey so i have created a simple workflow
just to show you how to publish
project in uipath
so here you can see the publish option
once you have created the project
go to the ribbon tab and click on the
publish
when you click the publish window opens
here you can change the package name if
you want you can see the version
new version package icon and release
notes
so let's click on next
here you will get the custom url where
you want to publish to
then click on publish
here you go you can see publishing
package
so a info dialog box appears project
published successfully
if you want you can copy to the
clipboard so this is how the project is
published in the ui path
what is data scraping and screen
scraping
data scraping is the process of
extracting structured data from a
browser
application or document and saving it to
a database
or a dot csv file or even an excel
spreadsheet
screen scraping methods are activities
that allow data to be extracted from a
specific ui element or document
such as a dot pdf file
explain the different types of
automation in uipath
excel automation excel automation is a
useful
tool for sorting deleting retrieving
and analyzing data it is simple to
migrate and integrate data
into platforms studio x has a strong
integration with microsoft excel and
ships with several activities
that automate excel tasks
mail automation enables task automation
with emails from the outlook desktop
application
gmail and outlook 365. add the
activities that use data from the
account inside the resource
activity after adding the account to the
automation
as a resource using a used outlook 365
use gmail
or use desktop outlook app activity
word automation in the word automation
add the word document to be worked on by
using a
word file activity and then add the word
activities to automate within the use
word file
powerpoint automation powerpoint
automation allows the user to automate
the most common task in powerpoint
presentation
add the presentation to work with the
use powerpoint presentation activity
and then inside the use powerpoint
presentation add the presentation
activities to automate
file automation it refers to the
automation of tasks
performed on your computer with files
and folders such as creating
copying or renaming files and folders
studio x includes several activities
that automate tasks that you perform
with files and folders
csv automation in csv automation
add the csv activities inside the use
excel file activity
where the excel file is defined to move
data between csv
and excel
explain a few read and write activities
read range read range reads the values
of an
excel range and stores in a data table
variable
read cell reads the values of an excel
cell and stores in a variable
read csv reads all entries from a
specified csv file
write range writes data from a data
table variable
to a spreadsheet write cell
writes a value or formula into a
specified spreadsheet cell
write csv overwrites a specified data
table to a csv file
what is an excel application scope
excel application scope opens an excel
workbook
and sets the scope for excel activities
when this activity is completed
the specified workbook and excel
application are closed
what is an orchestrator uipath
orchestrator is a web application
that orchestrates the execution of
repetitive process
it manages the creation monitoring
scheduling and controlling of bots and
process
it can manage the entire robot fleet
name some orchestrator capabilities
provisioning establishes and maintains
the connection between the robots and
the web application
deployment ensures that it delivers the
correct package versions to the assigned
robots for execution
configuration looks after the
maintenance and delivery of robot
environments and process configuration
queues queues ensures that it
automatically distributes the workload
across robots
monitoring manages user permissions and
keeps track of robot
recognition details logging
logs are stored and indexed in an sql
database
explain process job asset and queue
the process page allows you to build new
process
from uploaded packages managing existing
process
and keep all of your process up to date
with the latest package version
jobs on an uipath robot a job represents
the execution of procedure
it can start the execution of job in
either attended or unattended mode
queues a queue is a storage container
that can accommodate an
infinite number of objects multiple
types of data
such as invoice information or customer
data
are stored in queue objects other
systems such as sap or salesforce
are used to process this data
assets assets are usually shared
variables or credentials that can be
used through
several automation projects they allow
you to store unique information that the
robots can easily access
how to connect a robot to the
orchestrator
step 1 open ui path assistant
step 2 sign in the uipath orchestrator
step 3 create a tenant step 4
connect the robot to the orchestrator
and step 5
check the status it shows connected and
licensed
so let's see a demo of how to do this so
let's jump into the ui path studio
open you step 1 open ui path assistant
so we'll open uipath assistant
after opening uipath assistant login to
the uipath orchestrator
so go to the browser
go to the browser and type
platform.uipart.com
this will take to the uipath website
so sign in if you're new to this if you
don't have the account
then you can enter all the details and
log in
since i have already created an account
i'll sign in
after logging in the uipath orchestrator
go to the admin
here you can create a new tenant you can
add a tenant here and create a new
tenant since i have already created a
tenant
named admin so after creating a tenant
connect the robot to the orchestrator
go to the ui path assistant
go to preferences go to preferences
go to orchestrator settings
here you can see the status it is
offline click on the sign in button
once you click on the sign in button
allow this open ui path
here you can see it is connecting
and you can see where it is connected
and licensed
so the uipath robot is now connected
with the orchestrator
what is a tenant context and folder
context
in tenant context to view and control
tenant level entities in the
orchestrator
pick tenant from the sidebar menu with
only one instance of the orchestrator
multi-tenancy allows isolating data
for the folder context from this sidebar
menu pick any available folder
to view and control the entities within
the data folder
so i'll show you let's go to the
orchestrator
so let's go to the orchestrator
here you can see this is the tenant
context
to view and control the tenant level
entities in orchestrator you can pick
the tenant
from the sidebar menu from the sidebar
menu pick
any available folder so these are the
folders pick any available folder to
view and control the entities
within that folder so this is with
respect to the folder context
what is an re framework
the robotic enterprise framework is a
state machine based project template
it allows to handle even the most
complex business situations
it's designed to incorporate all of the
industry's best practices
for logging exception management
application initialization and other
areas
what are the features of re framework
settings during the initialization phase
of several process
some configuration settings and
configuration values
are frequently read like urls to a web
application
orchestrator queue names and default
logging messages
logging the built-in locking mechanism
is another helpful feature of the
framework the majority of the system's
workflows
use log message activities to output
information
about what is happening at each
execution stage
business exception if the issue is with
the data or any underlying business
requirement
the system skips the transaction and
moves on to the next
such exceptions are known as business
exceptions
application exception if the issue can
be resolved by restarting applications
the framework will do so automatically
and attempt to process the transaction
again
search exceptions are known as
application exceptions
how to merge two excel files into a
single excel file
first we need to create a sequence after
creating a sequence
we need a few activities like read csv
activity
assign activity data table activity and
write cs file activity
so we'll drag and drop all these
activities and do the process
then we'll run the sequence and see the
output
so let's jump into the ui path studio
and start with the
workflow
so we are in the uipath studio i have
already created a sequence
you can go to new and create a sequence
or press ctrl
n so after starting a sequence
first we will drag and drop read csv
activity
since we are using two excel files so we
need to read csv activity
we will drag and drop another read csv
activity
so we'll select the location of the
first excel file
select the first excel file
i'll show you both the excel files which
we are merging
so this is the first excel file so it
has
five rows five names
so will this is the first excel file
and
this is the second excel files this
excel file has five different names
and the other excel file has five
different rows
so these are the two excel files will
merge both these excel files
into a single new excel file
so we'll close this excel files
so in the first read csv activity we
have
copied the location of the first excel
file in the output 2
we will select this and create a
variable right click and create a
variable
and let's say name the variable as sl
underscore
five one
we have named a variable
okay now we'll go to another read csv
file
and select the location of the second
file
so i have downloaded the sample excel
files from the internet
just for the demo right click and create
a variable
let's say name this variable as sl
underscore file two
so now that we have dragged and drop to
read csv activities
now next we need assign activity
so drag and drop and assign activity
so assign activity has two parameters as
you can see
to and enter a vb expression
in the two parameter in this right click
and create a variable
and name the variable let's say
merged essay
after naming the variable enter an
expression here
so enter the expression as
sl underscore file 1 which is the
variable for
file 1 select this and
enter the expression dot clone
what this clone function does is the
clone function creates a new data table
with the same structure but does not
copy the data
so we are creating a new excel file that
is the third file
in which we are merging the data tables
of both the excel file
so the third excel file which we are
creating will have the same structure as
the
file one so this clone function creates
a third excel file
with the same structure as the file
button so it's showing an error
so select this assign let's go to
variables
here you can see variable type string
change it to system dot data dot data
table
and here you go the error is gone
okay so now we have dragged and dropped
assign activity
the next activity which we need is merge
data table activity
let's search for merge
data table activity drag and drop
modulatable activity we need two merge
data table activity since we have two
excel files
select the first merge data table
activity go to the destination
and enter the destination which is the
variable which we created in the assign
activity
the merged set so
enter this and enter the source file
that is the variable which you created
in file one that is
sl underscore file one
similarly similarly go to merge data
table
and enter the same destination
but here the source will be the second
file
okay now that we have dragged and
dropped too much data tables the next
activity
we need is a write csv file
so we'll search for write csv file
after dragging and dropping right csv
activity go to file path
and create a file create a file say
one will name it as file
3
save the file
now that we have created the file we'll
write
from the data table that is we need to
copy the merge data tab
so we'll enter
now that we have finished the program
the file is created
let's save and run it
process execution has started and ended
so let's go to the file
so this is the file which we created
let's open this file
and here you can see both the excel
files have been merged into a single
excel file
let's go to the next question how to
send a file over and
mail so first create a sequence
and create a file after you have created
a file
drag and drop get password activity
then drag and drop a smtp mail message
activity
so basically these two activities are
used to send a file over
mail then run the sequence so we'll
jump into the ui path studio and see
so this was the previous question which
we answered
how to merge two excel files so the same
file we will send it over and
mail so we need a get password activity
so we'll drag and drop a get password
activity
so if you go to the properties section
enter the password
to whichever mail you are sending this
file
enter the password of that mail id
[Music]
after entering the password in the
result go and create a variable
so that password is stored in that
variable so name the variable say
anything any randomly so i have named
the variable
after after this you need a
smtp mail message activity
so drag and drop send smtp mail message
in smtp mail message under the
properties pane
under the host enter the port value
for the port number which is 587
sorry after entering the port number
go to the server and enter it as
smtp.gmail.com
okay now after entering the email id
go to your email and enter your email id
to which you want to send this file
don't forget to use double quotes
otherwise it will show an error
enter the password so we had showed the
password in the variable
say sss so
we'll write that
so after that enter the email id here
under the two options
and enter the subject say it as demo
since we are showing a demo
we will enter the subject as demo this
is the this subject and body
is the subject and body of the mail
now let's attach the file which we have
created
copy the file location so
we'll go to the file and
copy this file location
after attaching the file
let's save android
the process has started and the process
has ended
here you can see in the output the
process has started and the process has
ended
let's go over the main and check if we
have received
here we go we have received the file
let's open the file
and here you go the same this is the
same file which had
merged the data so the file is been sent
over the
mail one thing you have to keep in mind
when you use the get password activity
go to your google account
in the security section
go to this secure app access and turn it
on
you have to turn it on to receive the
file over and mail
explain the different states and
transitions in re framework
there are four key states in re
framework
the first state is initial state this is
the point at which the procedure begins
it's an event where the process
initializes the settings
and runs application test to ensure that
all of the prerequisites for the process
start are met next we have get
transaction state this state retrieves
the next transaction object
this can be a queue item or a collection
item
transaction items are queue items by
default
but this can be modified to meet your
needs this is also when the developer
can set the condition
to exit the state when there are no
items to process
process transaction state for the
transaction item obtained in previous
step
it performs actions logic in various
application
if a transaction item has been processed
the process moves on to the next
transaction item available
end process state the procedure is
completed
and the applications open during
automations are closed
in the end process state let's
jump into the ui path studio and see
the different transitions in robotic
enterprise framework
so this is the robotic enterprise
framework this is the
initialization state the first state so
it has two
transitions system error that is system
exception
and successful when it shows system
exception when a system error is not
nothing
it gets transition to the end process
suppose if you have an application
exception during the initialization
phase and we don't have enough details
to start a process
then as a result we are going to end
process date to wrap it up
and the successful is when a system
error is nothing
it gets transition to get transaction
state
if during initialization we have no
error then
it goes to the get transaction data
the get transaction data has two
transitions
no data and new transaction
no data is when if the transaction item
is nothing then we are at the end of our
data collection
so it goes to the end process and in new
transaction
if the transaction item contains data
then it processes it
the process transaction data has three
transitions
success business exception and system
exception
success is when if the condition is
business rule exception is nothing
and system error is nothing then the
transition to get transaction data
if there is a business rule exception it
is logged and we move on to the next
transaction
and rule exception is if the business
rule exception is not nothing then it
gets transaction to the
get transaction data and the end process
does not have any transition since the
in process is the final state
so there are no transitions what is a g
suite activity
the uipath g-suite activity package
helps in the automation of google
workspace applications
such as google calendar google drive
google sheets gmail google docs
you can create and modify google
calendar events
manage google drive files read and send
gmail messages
and create new google sheets
spreadsheets and google documents with
the google g
suite activity package
what are selectors and wildcards in ui
path
wildcards are the symbols that enable
you to replace zero or multiple
characters in a string
this can be quite useful when dealing
with dynamically changing attributes in
a selector
selectors uipath studio uses what we
call selectors
they store the attributes of graphical
user interface element
and its parents in the shape of an xml
fragment
the selector aids in the automatic
generation of the selection
by utilizing wildcards
what is a machine explain standard
machine and machine template
the machine page allows you to provision
and manages machines to use them to
register robots with orchestrator
it displays the types of machine that we
currently in use
it enables you to design your machine
whether standard or template
standard machine it should be used when
the name of the machine on which you
want to define
robots is the same every time you
connect to it
you define the machine once and then you
can connect to as many robots as you
want from the robots page
machine template it should be used
whenever the name of the machine on
which you want to define
robot changes you represent this entity
once and then you use a unique active
directory username
to connect to any number of attended
floating robots
explain delay do if and switch
activities in ui path
the delay activity allows you to pause
the automation for a specified amount of
time
this activity is beneficial in projects
that require precise timing
such as waiting for a specific
application to start
or for some information to be processed
before using it in the another activity
the do activity allows you to run a
specific piece of automation
while the condition is met the project
exits the loop when the specified
condition is no longer completed
this activity can be used to iterate
through all the array elements
or execute a specific action multiple
times
if activity the effectivity includes a
statement
as well as two conditions if the
statement is true the first condition is
executed
if the statement is false the second
condition is executed
if activities can be used to make
decision based on variable values
switch activity the switch activity
allows you to choose
one of the several options based on the
value of specified expression
the switch activity uses an integer
argument by default
but you can change it in the properties
panel under the type argument list
the switch activity can be used to
categorize data based on predefined
number of cases
how to create chart in excel
step 1 create a new sequence go to the
ui path studio
and create a new sequence and then drag
and drop the following activities
to create a chart we need to use excel
application scope
create table activity and bar chart and
pie chart activity
depending on which type of charts you
want to create
then at last after completing then run
the sequence
we will see a demo of this in the uipath
studio
how to upload a file on drive so create
a new sequence and
drag and drop a g-suite application then
inside g-suite application
drag and drop upload file activity fill
in the details
and finally run the suite let's go and
see a demo
to how to create charts in excel file
and how to upload a file on the drive
so let's jump into the uipath studio
this is the excel file which i have
created
it has all the number of cases in this
five states
in the year 2021 the month of jan feb
march and april
all this record i have taken it from a
website called
prs india dot org
so i have two sheets sheet one and sheet
two
so let's jump into the ui path studio
to start off with the demo we need to
have the three packages
installed one is the ui path
excel activities package the other one
is uipath g suite dot activities
this activity this package is used for
drive
to upload only drive then
the other package is balareva excel
activities
this package is used for bar graph and
pie chart
so after installing these three
packages we'll get started
so let's create a new sequence name it
as sequence
2
so first we'll drag and drop an excel
application scope
so excel application scope what it does
is
it opens an excel workbook and sets the
scope for excel activities
when this activity is completed the
specified workbook and excel
applications
are closed when the workbook application
variable is specified in the output
for book activities field the
spreadsheet is not closed
after this drag and drop a create table
activity
so by default we have sheet one and
enter the range so the range is
in this excel sheet the range is from a1
to
f5 so enter the range
for this we need to enter the file path
so we'll select the file
so we have selected the file we have
entered the
enter the table name say
number of cases
so once this much is done next we'll
drag and drop a
bar chart
drop it outside the excel application
scroll and select the file path
so select the file
so select the file select this cell
range
that is the same range what we had
entered earlier
a1 to f5
so once that is done if the chart title
say basis
and you can select the chart type
bar stack 3d clustered 3d stand whatever
is required
for now we will select bar cluster
we have many other options to explore
data label type will keep it in
show value so that it shows the value
and select show value
if you want show percentage you can
select percentage
will select show legend and size
you can vary the size accordingly how
much ever you want so i'll keep the size
as
350
to 350. you can change the width
so the bar chart is done and you can
enter the sheet which sheet are you
using so it's sheet one
now we will drag and drop pie chart
select the file
similarly enter the options here
enter the cell range the same range
a1 is to f5
show percent will show value
show legend
select show value
and select the sheet which you are we'll
select the sheet 2.
so done so we have completed till here
next we need to upload this on the
google drive
so we'll select this option upload file
select the file
so we have selected the file so select
the destination folder
for that go to your google drive account
so we'll go there
so in my drive i have created a folder
called excel automation
so i'll copy this url
till here not the entire copter this
and go to your ui patch studio and paste
it in the destination folder
you get double quotes
then create a variable and
create a variable as file
oops there is an error
oh we have forgotten to use a g-suite
application
this can be only used inside a g suite
application
so drag and drop a g suite application
and inside g suite application
we'll write this so there is god
so we'll run the file now we'll save it
and run
you can see the file is getting run
so the execution is endless we will
navigate to the drive
so here you can see the file is
successfully uploaded
we'll open the file
it's working on the graph
here you go here you can see the bar
graph
for the sheet one with the values
number of values and each state wise and
for sheet 2
we created a pie chart so here you go
here you can see the project
so with that we have come to the end of
the rpa ui path full course tutorial
if you enjoyed watching it make sure to
hit the subscribe button
and press the bell icon to never miss an
update
thank you so much for being here watch
out for more videos from us
until then keep learning and stay tuned
to simply learn